MR. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GIL
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. ATKINS.
BECKER. BLAKE SPEER. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ DALLEY. DODD
DURAZO. EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ.
GROVE. HURTADO JONES. LAIRD.
LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN
NEWMAN. NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO.
SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. STERN UMBERG. WAHAB.
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THEIR MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THANK
YOU. AS WE GATHER TODAY, WE PRAY
IN THE WORDS OF RABINDRANATH
TAGORE, THIS IS MY PRAYER TO
YOU, O LORD. STRIKE! STRIKE AT
THE ROOT OF PENURY IN MY HEART.
GIVE ME STRENGTH LIGHTLY TO BEAR
MY JOYS AND SORROWS. GIVE ME
STRENGTH TO MAKE MY LOVE
FRUITFUL IN SERVICE. GIVE ME
STRENGTH NEVER TO DISOWN THE
POOR OR BEND MY KNEES BEFORE
INSOLENT MIGHT. GIVE ME STRENGTH
TO RAISE MY MIND HIGH ABOVE
DAILY TRIFLES. AND GIVE ME
STRENGTH TO SURRENDER MY
STRENGTH TO YOUR WILL WITH LOVE.
AMEN. MEMBERS, JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE UNITED STATES OF REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS. NOW IS THE
TIME WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
TRIBUTES TO OUR OUTGOING
SENATORS. SO WE WOULD ASK THAT
MEMBERS TAKE THEIR SEATS SO WE
CAN PROPERLY RECOGNIZE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. FIRST UP IS SENATOR,
I MEAN, ATKINS. I'M SORRY. AND
SHE'S JOINED TODAY BY HER
PARTNER, CHEN BLAKESPEAR. SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH SENATOR EGGMAN.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. OH, YEAH.
RECOGNITION OF OUR OUTGOING
MEMBERS. EACH PRESENTER. OKAY.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY. AND
BEFORE I START ON MY FRIEND
TONY, I'M GOING TO TAKE A MEMO
FROM SENATOR BRADFORD'S TALK AND
DIDN'T. I DIDN'T GET TO SAY
ENOUGH LAST NIGHT BECAUSE I WAS
TRYING TO STICK TO THE TIME. SO
NOW GET COMFORTABLE, FOLKS,
LOOKING AT YOU, BEN ALLEN, I
REALLY, REALLY WANT TO AGAIN,
THANK MY STAFF. I HAVE BEEN SO
BLESSED TO HAVE A TEAM THAT HAS
STAYED WITH ME ALMOST MY ENTIRE
TIME. I COULD NOT HAVE DONE THE
THINGS THAT I'VE DONE WITH THEM,
AND THAT GOES TO COMMITTEE STAFF
TO CAUCUS STAFF, TO ALL THE
STAFF I'VE WORKED WITH AND MOST
ESPECIALLY AS PEOPLE KNOW, I
CAME HERE FROM BEING A SOCIAL
WORK PROFESSOR AND REALLY WANTED
TO BRING MY PROFESSION INTO THIS
BUILDING. AND I'M PROUD OF THE
SOCIAL WORKERS THAT HAVE COME
OUT OF MY OFFICE AND CONTINUE TO
DO GOOD WORK. LEAH BURROWS,
GUSTAVO MEDINA, LAUREN EVANS,
ELIZABETH CARRANZA AND STILL IN
MY OFFICE AS ANNA, BILLY AND
JACOB, ALL MSW. HOPEFULLY
INCREASING THE WORK THAT WE DO.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I ALWAYS
TOLD THEM WAS TO ON THE SIDE OF
GENEROSITY AND KINDNESS. AND
THAT'S HOW I WANT TO START OFF
TALKING ABOUT MY FRIEND TONY
ATKINS. IF ANYBODY ALWAYS ERRS
ON THE SIDE OF GENEROSITY AND
KINDNESS, IT IS MY FRIEND,
FORMER PRO TEM EMERITUS TONY
ATKINS. IT HAS BEEN MY HONOR TO
SERVE IN TWO HOUSES WITH HER,
BUT ESPECIALLY IN THIS HOUSE
HERE WHERE I THINK ALL OF OUR
WORK REALLY CAME TO A LOT OF
FRUITION. AS PEOPLE KNOW, TONY
CAME FROM APPALACHIA, FROM A
PLACE THAT DIDN'T HAVE RUNNING
WATER. AND SO FOR MANY OF US WHO
COME FROM VERY WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES, WE CAN GET A SENSE OF
IMPOSTER SYNDROME WHEN WE GO
INTO DIFFERENT SPACES WHERE
PEOPLE DON'T EXPECT US TO BE AND
CERTAINLY WE OR OUR FAMILIES
NEVER EXPECTED US TO BE. I HAVE
NEVER SEEN ANYBODY WITH MORE
CONFIDENCE AND MORE AT EASE WITH
HERSELF AND COMFORTABLE IN HER
OWN SKIN, NO MATTER WHAT THE
SETTING. AS MY FRIEND TONY
ATKINS. AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
HER EXCEL AND TO SHINE AND TO BE
THE LEADER THAT SHE IS, THAT
TRUE COMFORT IN WHO SHE IS AND
WHAT HER MISSION IS. AND THAT
NORTH STAR OF SERVING PEOPLE,
WHETHER IT IS PASSING INCREDIBLY
REFORM, HOUSING POLICY, WHETHER
IT IS ENSURING A WOMAN HAS EVERY
CHANCE THAT SHE CAN HAVE TO HAVE
CONTROL OVER HER OWN BODY,
WHETHER IT'S OUR VETERANS ISSUE.
SHE HAS A HUGE HEART FOR
VETERANS. OUR AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY, A LOT OF FOOD HAS
CONTINUED TO BE GROWN HERE
BECAUSE OF TONY ATKINS AND HER
INTEREST IN FARMING AND WORKING
PEOPLE, AND HOW ALL THOSE THINGS
COME TOGETHER WHEN IT COMES TO
BEING A LEADER. IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO IT WITH
MORE CALMNESS? AGAIN, RESPECT
AND KINDNESS, MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS ROOM FOR US ALL AS OUR
FRIEND TONY ATKINS, WE KNOW SHE
LOVES DOLLY PARTON AND WE KNOW
IT'S BECAUSE SHE SEES THAT SAME
AUTHENTICITY. NOT QUITE AS MUCH
BLING, BUT ALL THE STYLE THAT
MIGHT COME WITH THAT. PEOPLE SAY
THE TRUE MEASURE OF A LEADER IS
WHAT THEY DO WHEN NOBODY IS EVEN
WATCHING. I DON'T KNOW IF PEOPLE
KNOW. TONY ATKINS IS A HUGE
HEART FOR THOSE ON OUR STREETS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES,
ESPECIALLY VETERANS. I HAVE
WALKED WITH HER ON THE STREETS,
THINGS THAT AGAIN, PEOPLE DON'T
EVEN KNOW. THIS ONE GENTLEMAN
WHO SHE'S KIND OF ADOPTED. WE
COME ALONG HIM ONE NIGHT AND SHE
STOPS. SHE ASKS HIM HOW HE IS,
IF HIS DOG NEEDS SOME FOOD, IF
HE'S COLD. IT WAS KIND OF
RAINING. IT WAS KIND OF COLD. WE
THEN WENT TO HER PLACE WHERE SHE
LOOKED THROUGH HER CLOSET. SHE
FOUND A QUILT AND SHE SAID, OH
MY. MY FORMER GIRLFRIEND GAVE ME
THIS, BUT WE HAD A GOOD 17 YEARS
AND THIS QUILT KEPT ME STRONG.
AND WE WENT BACK OUT THERE AND
SHE COVERED THAT MAN WITH HER
QUILT FROM HER FIRST PARTNER,
JANA. SORRY, JANA, IF YOU'RE
LISTENING, BUT HE WAS WARM FOR A
NIGHT AND SOMETIMES THAT'S WHAT
IT JUST TAKES, RIGHT? SOMEBODY
WHO SEES PEOPLE. SOMEBODY WHO
CARES ABOUT PEOPLE AND SOMEBODY
WHO IS ADDICTED TO
RESPONSIBILITY AND WHO DOESN'T
SHY AWAY FROM HARD THINGS, WHO
BRINGS A TEAM TOGETHER AND MAKES
SURE THINGS GET DONE. SO THAT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
HAD THE BENEFIT OF HER SERVICE.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S DONE YET,
AND I THINK THERE'S A NEXT
BIGGER SEAT FOR TONY ATKINS TO
SIT IN IN OUR GREAT STATE. BUT
FOR NOW, SHE HAS BEEN THE FIRST
ONE WHO HAS BEEN THE LEADER OF
TWO HOUSES AGAIN, JUST A LITTLE
GAL FROM APPALACHIA WHO TOOK
CALIFORNIA BY STORM WITH
KINDNESS AND GENEROSITY. I WILL
FOREVER BE GRATEFUL TO YOU FOR
THE CHANCES THAT YOU GAVE TO ME,
AND I'M SURE OUR FRIENDSHIP WILL
REMAIN STRONG THE REST OF OUR
LIVES. I LOVE YOU, TONY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN. NEXT
UP FOR THE TRIBUTE WILL BE
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT, I, UNLIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON, HAD TO
KEEP MY NOTES BECAUSE IF I GO
OFF SCRIPT OR GO ROGUE, I
PROBABLY WOULD MAKE IT THROUGH
THIS. SO, COLLEAGUES, IT'S HARD
TO PUT INTO WORDS HOW MUCH I
WILL MISS SERVING WITH SENATE
PRO TEM EMERITUS TONI ATKINS. WE
SELDOM AGREE ON ANY POLICY AND
NOT EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS OUR
FRIENDSHIP. I'VE SERVED WITH
TONI, LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON, SINCE 2010, WHEN WE
STARTED IN THE ASSEMBLY. SHE
TRULY IS A WELL-ROUNDED LEADER
THAT COVERS EVERY END OF THE
SPECTRUM, FROM BEING BORN AND
RAISED IN THE APPALACHIAN
MOUNTAINS IN ROANOKE, TO SITTING
SIDE BY SIDE WITH THE GOVERNOR
AS THE FIRST WOMAN ELECTED AS A
SENATE PRO TEMPORE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, SHE
EXUDES EXCELLENCE AND CLASS. SHE
IS DEMURE AND POLISHED, BUT
SHE'S ALSO LIKE THAT AMERICAN
GIRL THAT FANTASTIC
REPRESENTATION OF THE SIMPLE
WORKING CLASS TRYING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. IT'S ALMOST LIKE THAT
1980S HAIRCUT, THE MULLET. WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT, SHE'S ALL
BUSINESS UP FRONT AND SHE'S
PARTY IN THE BACK. FROM
CHAMPAGNE TASTE TO FLUEVOG SHOES
TO MANAGING POLICY PACKAGES AND
NEGOTIATING BUDGET DEALS DURING
THE DAY AND MAKING SURE EVERY
MEMBER IN GOOD TIMES GOT
SOMETHING FOR THEIR DISTRICT AND
THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT TO
GOING HOME SINGING DOLLY PARTON
AND GLEN CAMPBELL, OR JUST GOOD
OLD GOSPEL WITH A HAIRBRUSH,
MICROPHONE, DANCING IN THE
KITCHEN WHILE MAKING EGG CUSTARD
PIES. BOTH OF OUR MAMA'S
FAVORITES. SHE REPRESENTS IT
ALL. COMING FROM A POOR WORKING
CLASS BACKGROUND, SHE
UNDERSTANDS HARD WORK AND
PERSEVERANCE AND BIG DREAMS.
SHE'S THE EMBODIMENT OF
DETERMINATION. I HAD THE GREAT
HONOR OF SERVING AS A SENATE
MINORITY LEADER WHEN TONI WAS AS
DIFFERENT AS WE ARE. WE WORK
SIDE BY SIDE IN OUR FRIENDSHIP
AND RESPECT FOR EACH OTHER GREW
DURING THAT TIME AND WAS
STRONGER THAN IT WAS BEFORE.
WE'VE TWINNED IT ON THIS FLOOR
FOR TWO YEARS AND WE HAVE WON
FIRST PLACE BOTH YEARS IN A ROW.
I THINK DURING OUR LEADERSHIP
TOGETHER, WE CERTAINLY WENT
THROUGH SOME OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIMES AND THE MOST
EXCITING TIMES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THOUGHT LONG AND
HARD ABOUT SOME OF THE STORIES I
WOULD TELL, BUT I'M GOING TO
STICK TO THIS STATEMENT, AND I'M
GOING TO TELL YOU THAT YOU GOT
TO BUY THE BOOK WITH ALL THE
STUFF THAT WE DID IN LEADERSHIP.
I CAN'T SHARE IT TODAY, BUT WHEN
WE'RE BOTH OUT OF POLITICS, I
GUARANTEE YOU IT WILL BE A
BESTSELLER. WE WERE TOGETHER IN
2019 WHEN THE WHEN OUR MEMBERS
WERE ASSAULTED BY BODILY FLUIDS.
FLU THAT FLUNG RIGHT OVER THAT
BALCONY ONTO OUR DESK RIGHT HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS, WHICH LED TO A
VERY EVENTFUL END OF SESSION IN
A COMMITTEE ROOM, WHICH WAS
CERTAINLY THE FIRST FOR MOST OF
US, IF NOT ALL, OF US.
NATURALLY, WE FOLLOWED UP THE
BLOOD CURSE OF 2019 WITH A
WORLDWIDE PLAGUE IN 2020, AND
NEITHER OF THESE WERE FUN. BOTH
OF US WERE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING TO COME IN 2021.
NONE OF US KNEW WHAT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN THROUGH THE PANDEMIC,
AND WE HAD TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
AND SUPPORT OF NOT ONLY OUR
STAFF HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE,
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST, OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS. TONY ALWAYS MADE
SURE, ALWAYS MADE SURE THAT MY
STAFF AND I WERE LOOPED IN AND
BRIEFED IN THE EVER CHANGING
SITUATION AGAIN. WE DIDN'T AGREE
ON ALL THE POLICY, BUT TONY
ALWAYS ENSURED EVERYONE WAS
EQUALLY PREPARED AND COMPLETELY
IN THE KNOW HER FIRST PRIORITY
AND HER PRIORITY THAT WILL
CONTINUE IN HER FUTURE. ALWAYS
HAS BEEN AND ALWAYS WILL BE. THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND SHE NEVER LET
PARTY AFFILIATION GET AWAY, GET
IN THE WAY OF THAT GOAL. SHE'S
FAIR AND INCLUSIVE, ONE OF THE
FEW MEMBERS THAT UNDERSTANDS
THAT REPUBLICANS REPRESENT
ROUGHLY JUST OVER A MILLION
PEOPLE IN EACH OF THEIR
DISTRICTS, VERY DIFFERENT THAN A
LOT OF YOURS. BUT SHE
UNDERSTANDS THAT WE TOO DESERVE
REPRESENTATION FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ONE GREAT EXAMPLE OF
THAT, WHEN I WAS LEADER, SHE
APPROACHED ME AND ALLOWED A
REPUBLICAN TO CHAIR A COMMITTEE.
DURING HER TENURE AS LEADER.
THIS WAS UNPRECEDENTED. SHE LED
A CENTER THAT REPRESENTED THE
TOP FOOD PRODUCING COUNTY IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD. BE THE CHAIR OF
THE AG COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT MADE
SENSE. SHE ESTABLISHED THE
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT WITH
FORMER SENATE REPUBLICAN LEADER
PAT BATES. TWO WOMEN, TWO
DIFFERENT PARTIES WORKING HARD
TOGETHER TO CHANGE THE CULTURE
OF THIS BUILDING. SHE'S FOUGHT
TO EXPAND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN, INCLUDING ESTABLISHING
A STATEWIDE PROGRAM TO INCREASE
LITERACY RATES ACROSS THE STATE.
THE RT AND I ARE SO PROUD THAT
WE BROUGHT DOLLY PARTON'S
IMAGINATION LIBRARY STATEWIDE,
AND THE CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
NOW HAVE ACCESS TO READING BOTH
ENGLISH AND SPANISH TRANSLATIONS
OF ONE OF OUR GREATEST ROLE
MODELS, WHO CARES DEEPLY ABOUT
EVERYONE WHO TONY IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF. SHE SUPPORTED
VETERANS AND WOMEN, ESPECIALLY
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE AND
SEX TRAFFICKING. AND ALSO, WE
ALL KNOW THAT WE SERVE SIDE BY
HER SIDE. WE ARE SO PROUD THAT
SHE IS THE ONLY WOMAN THAT HAS
LED BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THE BEAUTIFUL THING
ABOUT MY FRIEND IS THAT SHE
LEADS WITH DIGNITY AND GRACE.
SHE HAS QUITE THE STRENGTH AND
SHE DOESN'T HAVE TO FLAUNT IT.
IT'S VERY WELL UNDERSTOOD AND
DEMANDS WANTS RESPECT WHEN SHE
JUST ENTERS THE ROOM. HER
COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT IS WHAT
MAKES HER INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL,
AND IT'S EVIDENT BY THE FACT
THAT I'M HERE GIVING THIS SPEECH
TODAY. BUT LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING. SHE'S BENEFITED FROM
KNOWING ME TOO. IT'S NOT ONE
SIDED. YOU WOULD THINK, BECAUSE
SHE'S PRESTIGIOUS AND POWERFUL
IN THESE POSITIONS THAT SHE'S
HELD AS SPEAKER AND SENATE PRO
TEMPORE, THAT SHE MAY ONLY HAVE
CHAMPAGNE TASTE. BUT IT'S MY
HUSBAND THAT HAS PROVEN TO HER
THAT CRACKING OPEN A COLD BEER
OR A COLD COORS LIGHT ON A HOT
SUMMER DAY, RIDING A SIDE BY
SIDE WITH RICK WHILE CHASING GIN
AND I ON HORSEBACK IS A LOT OF
FUN TO. ALSO, SHE WEARS MY
CLOTHES. SERIOUSLY. SHE HAS
PROBABLY 20 OF MY DRESSES I
THINK ARE SIMILAR BACKGROUNDS.
REALLY UNITED US BOTH GROWING UP
IN POOR POOR FAMILIES WHERE OUR
MAMAS WERE THE BACKBONE OF THE
FAMILY AND THE ROLE MODEL OF
KINDNESS AND PERSEVERANCE. NEVER
SETTLING FOR THE STATUS QUO,
ALWAYS PUSHING US TO BE OUR VERY
BEST, I THINK BONDED US TOGETHER
MORE THAN ANYTHING. SHE DID MAKE
ONE BIG MISTAKE IN OUR
RELATIONSHIP. SHE CONNECTED ME
WITH HER TWIN SISTER, TINA, A
FELLOW VETERAN. TINA MAKES ME
LOOK LIKE A LIBERAL, NO JOKE.
TINA MAKES ME LOOK LIKE A
LIBERAL. AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WHENEVER TINA IS IN TOWN, TONY
IS OUTVOTED. ALWAYS 2 TO 1.
HANDS DOWN. THAT IS A REALLY
GOOD FEELING COMING FROM A
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN. THE
BEST THING ABOUT TONY IS THAT
SHE'S OPEN MINDED AND ALWAYS
WILLING TO WORK WITH THOSE
AROUND HER. HER EMPATHY,
HUMILITY, COMMUNICATION SKILLS,
AND EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE
PROPEL HER FORWARD AND DRIVE HER
TO BE ONE OF THE MOST INCREDIBLE
LEADERS I'VE EVER KNOWN. EVIDENT
BY THE EXPECTATION THAT SHE HAS
FOR ALL OF US ON THIS FLOOR WITH
HER CONGENIALITY, BECAUSE WE
REPRESENT THE RED CARPET. I'M
FOREVER GRATEFUL TO HAVE SERVE
BY YOUR SIDE IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE. BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, I'M FOREVER
GRATEFUL TO CALL YOU MY FRIEND.
AND FRANKLY, YOU AND JEN ARE
JUST GOOD PEOPLE. I KNOW WE WILL
MISS YOU VERY MUCH, BUT THERE
ARE BIG THINGS IN STORE FOR YOU,
AND I LEAVE YOU WITH ONE OF MY
FAVORITE SCRIPTURES. BE ON YOUR
GUARD. BE ON YOUR GUARD. STAND
FIRM IN FAITH AND BE COURAGEOUS.
AND BE STRONG AND ALWAYS BE YOU,
BECAUSE YOU ARE THE DAUGHTER OF
BETTY CATHERINE DAVIS ADKINS.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING TO HAVE A
LEGACY TO FOLLOW. COLLEAGUES,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING MY
FRIEND TONI ATKINS.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE.
SENATOR ATKINS, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
TO MY COLLEAGUES, TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD. I'M
PRETTY SURE HALF OF THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN IN THE BOOK, BUT
THAT'S THAT'S GREAT. AND TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON, JOHN, I
DIDN'T WANT THAT QUILT. THAT'S
WHY I HAD IT. SO I'M PRETTY SURE
WE'RE COOL, YOU KNOW, THANK YOU
FOR THOSE ELOQUENT, ELOQUENT
REMARKS. I, I'M BLOWN AWAY. YOU
KNOW, I THOUGHT TODAY I TOLD
CHEN, YOU DON'T NEED TO COME.
IT'S JUST GOING TO BE A SIMPLE
THREE MINUTE THING. AND I REALLY
FEEL LIKE I HAVE HAD MY 15
MINUTES OF FAME, AND THERE ARE
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT DESERVE IT.
SO I'M GOING TO TAKE A MINUTE
AND THANK THOSE FOLKS. BUT TO MY
TWO COLLEAGUES THAT SPOKE TODAY,
YOU ARE DEAR FRIENDS. AND YES, I
LOVE RICK AND I LOVE EMMY AND
RENEE, AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE FRIENDS. OUR TIME TOGETHER
HAS GIVEN US THE ABILITY TO
FORGE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS, AND I
AM FOREVER GRATEFUL. AS I SAY,
ALL THE TIME. AND, YOU MIMICKED
ME YESTERDAY PERFECTLY. I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN A WE. I'VE NEVER
BEEN A ME. I AM A TWIN. I PLAYED
TEAM SPORTS. IT IS HOW I THRIVE
BEST, WHICH IS WORKING WITH EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU. AND I AM
GRATEFUL FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE
ALLOWED ME TO DO. TO ALLOW A
LITTLE GIRL FROM APPALACHIA WHO
DIDN'T BELIEVE SOCIETY OR
GOVERNMENT WAS ABOUT ME, OR FOR
ME TO BE ABLE TO BE IN THIS
POSITION AND SHOW PEOPLE LIKE ME
AND FAMILIES LIKE OURS, BECAUSE
WE ALL HAVE STORIES. YOU ALL
HAVE STORIES TO SHOW PEOPLE IN
THIS STATE THAT GOVERNMENT CAN
BE ABOUT THEM, AND WE CAN DO
GOOD THINGS DESPITE OUR
DIFFERENCES IN HOW TO DO THOSE
THINGS. AND I BELIEVE THAT EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU CAME TO
SERVE YOUR CONSTITUENTS. AND
THAT'S WHAT I REMEMBERED BECAUSE
TO THE STAFF HERE WHO HAVE
SERVED ALL OF US SO WELL, IT
REALLY IS ALWAYS ABOUT THE
CONSTITUENTS. AND IF YOU
REMEMBER THAT, WE'LL ALL GO A
LONG WAY TOGETHER. I WANT TO
THANK JENNIFER FOR BEING HERE
TODAY, 24 YEARS TOGETHER, 24
PLUS, YOU KNOW, 14 YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE FLYING UP EVERY
MONDAY, FLYING HOME. AND THEN,
OF COURSE, STEPPING INTO TWO
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AND
REALIZING THAT I WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY ALWAYS BE HOME. AND,
YOU KNOW, SHE IS HER OWN PERSON.
SHE IS HER OWN INDIVIDUAL. SHE
OWNS BUSINESSES. SHE'S GOT STUFF
TO DO. AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY TO TUESDAY IS HER
BUSIEST DAY OF THE WEEK. SO I AM
HONORED BY YOUR SUPPORT, YOUR
LOVE, YOUR FRIENDSHIP AND ALL
THAT YOU'VE HELPED ME LEARN OVER
THE LAST 24 YEARS TOGETHER.
THANK YOU. JENNIFER THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, THE WE PART I HAVE HAD
INCREDIBLE STAFF EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY. THE ENTIRE 14 YEARS
I'VE BEEN HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY,
IN THE SENATE. AND IT'S JUST
AMAZING THAT MANY OF THEM ARE
HERE TODAY, I WILL NEVER BE ABLE
TO THANK YOU ENOUGH. AND I CAN'T
LOOK AT YOU. ALTHOUGH I REALLY I
REALLY WANT TO JUST KNOW, THE
WORK WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
TOGETHER ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. BUT AND I SAY
THIS, I, YOU KNOW, I REALLY LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE. I THINK IT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CRITICAL. AND
I STARTED CALLING THE SPEAKER
STAFF AND THE RT STAFF, THE
INFRASTRUCTURE STAFF. AND THEN I
REALIZED THEY MIGHT NOT THINK
THAT'S A COMPLIMENT, BUT,
INCREDIBLE, INCREDIBLE TEAMS IN
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE. I SEE YOU HERE TODAY,
YOU MAKE EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
US LOOK GOOD. YOU DO THE WORK, I
MEAN, I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW TO
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'VE DONE FOR ME TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE JOB IN LEADERSHIP
AND FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IT'S ALSO THE
STAFF IN THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS.
YOU KNOW, WE ALL, EXPECT A GREAT
DEAL OUT OF ALL OF YOU. AND YOU
DELIVER EACH AND EVERY TIME,
EACH AND EVERY TIME. SO CAN WE
THANK OUR INCREDIBLE STAFFS WHO
DO THIS WORK? YOU KNOW, I'VE HAD
STAFF, YOU KNOW, WHO COME AND DO
INCREDIBLE THINGS, AND THEN THEY
GET OTHER OPPORTUNITIES AND THEY
MOVE ON. AND LET ME JUST TELL
YOU HOW YOU'VE PASSED THE BATON
TO THE NEXT CHIEF OF STAFF OR
THE NEXT POLICY DIRECTOR OR THE
NEXT DISTRICT DIRECTOR, HOW EACH
OF YOU HAVE PROFESSIONALLY
MANAGED THAT AND MADE SURE THAT
YOUR SUCCESSOR STEPS IN AND
CONTINUES TO DO THE WORK. I AM
JUST SO GRATEFUL TO EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU. I, I THINK IT
WAS DIANE WHO SAID, WE SHOULD
ALL BE STOOPED OVER ME AND NICK
HARDIMAN AND DIANE FOR HOW OFTEN
WE PAT OURSELVES ON THE BACK FOR
THE FACT THAT WE FOUND ERIKA
CONTRERAS AND HOW WONDERFUL IT
WAS TO HAVE HER TAKE THIS
POSITION AND HAVE ALL OF YOU
VOTE ON HER TO BECOME THE
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE,
ESPECIALLY AS WE APPROACH THOSE
CRISES THAT, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD TALKED ABOUT, YOU
ROSE TO EVERY OCCASION YOU PUT
TOGETHER THE TEAM. I KNOW THAT
YOU ARE SOMEONE THAT THAT, YOU
KNOW, REALLY WANTS TO GIVE
CREDIT TO, ALL THOSE THAT HELP
YOU DO THAT WORK. AND SO I CAN
NEVER THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR WHAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO HELP US WITH THE WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT, TO GET THAT UP.
AND RUNNING AND YOUR RESPECT FOR
EACH MEMBER AS WE SET THE TONE
ON THIS FLOOR, ONE OF THE
GREATEST COMPLIMENTS YOU'VE
GIVEN ME AND OTHERS HAVE HAS
BEEN THE TONE OF COLLEGIALITY
THAT WE HAVE SET IN THE SENATE,
REGARDLESS OF POLITICAL
PHILOSOPHY, WE HAVE SOME HARD
TIMES AND HARD DISCUSSIONS, AND
OUT OF THIS BUILDING, WE HAVE
SOME HARD POLITICAL BATTLES. BUT
WHEN WE COME HERE, MOST OF THE
WORK WE DO TOGETHER, WE AGREE
UPON. AND WHEN WE DON'T, WE MAKE
OUR CASE. BUT WE LEAVE. WE WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS FLOOR AND WE
MANAGED TO FIGURE IT OUT AND
STILL BE RESPECTFUL TO EACH
OTHER. EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
AND I THINK THAT SETS US APART.
I THINK IT IS A GREAT MODEL AND
EXAMPLE FOR OTHERS. HOW YOU
SHOULD CONDUCT THE BUSINESS OF
THE PEOPLE, BECAUSE WE REPRESENT
A VERY DIVERSE GROUP OF PEOPLE.
AND I DON'T JUST MEAN IN TERMS
OF ETHNIC OR GENDER. WE
REPRESENT DIFFERENT
PHILOSOPHIES. NOT EVERYBODY IS A
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN IN THIS
STATE. THERE'S A HECK OF A LOT
OF DECLINE TO STATES AND NO
PARTY PREFERENCES AND LOTS OF
OTHERS. SO WE REPRESENT EVERYONE.
WELL, I WANT TO THANK ONE OF THE
FIRST PEOPLE I MET WHEN I WAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY. MY MENTOR, CHRIS
KEHOE, BROUGHT ME OVER HERE, AND
SHE WAS SO EXCITED TO INTRODUCE
ME TO BERNIE. SHE SAID, BERNIE
KNOWS EVERYTHING AND WE'VE
STATED THAT AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN. AND TO BERNIE AND THE
FLOOR TEAM, WE ARE SO GRATEFUL.
I KNOW I'M STILL IN THE TAIL END
OF SESSION SPEECH, BUT WE CAN
NEVER THANK THE PEOPLE THAT HELP
US ENOUGH. THE SERGEANTS, ADRIAN
AND MICHAEL, WHO HAVE TAKEN
REALLY GOOD CARE OF ME, THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND TO THE EXTENDED
ALL OF THE SERGEANTS AND,
KATRINA, I WANT TO THANK YOU IN
SAN DIEGO, I GOT SOME INCREDIBLE
RETIRED ANNUITANT CHP OFFICERS
THAT ARE JUST INCREDIBLE, AND I
DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY DISTRICT
STAFF, WHO ARE PROBABLY
LISTENING. JASON, ALL OF YOU.
PAM HAS MOVED ON. BUT TO ALL OF
THE DISTRICT STAFF I'VE HAD ALL
THESE YEARS, 14 YEARS, YOU HAVE
ALLOWED ME TO STEP INTO THE
SPEAKERSHIP ROLE AND THE PRO TEM
SHIP, KNOWING THAT YOU'RE TAKING
CARE OF THE CONSTITUENTS AT
HOME, KNOWING THAT I'M GOING TO
BE ANXIOUS IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
BUSINESS OF MY CONSTITUENTS
BEING TAKEN CARE OF. AND TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON, THANK
YOU FOR SAYING I DO IT WITH
CALMNESS AND ALL THOSE THINGS.
MY STAFF KNOW. MY SPOUSE KNOWS
THAT UNDERNEATH ALL THAT IS
GREAT ANXIETY. AND WHEN I HAVE A
TEAM LIKE THEM AND ALL OF YOU,
MY LEADERSHIP TEAM, MR. PETE AND
ALL OF YOU, HELPING GET THE JOB
DONE, THEN I'M CALM AND I RELAX
BECAUSE WE GOT IT TOGETHER. WE
GOT IT. AND TO THOSE OF YOU THAT
GAVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY, I MEAN,
ALL OF YOU, FOR LETTING ME DO
THE POSITION OF PRO TEM. LET ME
THANK YOU. YOU HELPED ME. YOU
HELPED ME SO MUCH TO GROW AND TO
LEARN AND TO SEE THE DIFFERENT
LENS THAT EACH OF US PUTS THINGS
THROUGH AND HOW THAT'S IMPORTANT
AND HOW IT COMES TOGETHER, I AM
GOING TO TAKE ONE, ONE MOMENT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE. THERE ARE
TWO PEOPLE HERE TODAY THAT VOTED
FOR ME TO BE SPEAKER AND PRO
TEM. MR. PRESIDENT, I WANT TO
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY. I THINK WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT THE SHOES OUTSIDE OF
HERE TO DETERMINE WHO YOU KNOW,
WHO HAS MORE FLUEVOGS. BUT
NANCY, THANK YOU, AND THERE ARE
A FEW OTHERS. MR. PORTANTINO ICU
AND, OF COURSE, MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES WHERE WE CAME IN
TOGETHER, YOU WERE SORT OF DRUG
ALONG. YOU HAD TO SUPPORT ME AT
ONE POINT BECAUSE WE HAD A
MAJORITY. BUT BUT YOU DIDN'T YOU
DIDN'T OPPOSE ME. SO I TAKE THAT
AS A WIN, AND I MOVE FORWARD, SO
I WANT TO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT GRACIOUSNESS, BUT TO
THE COLLEAGUES THAT HELPED ME
SEE THAT I COULD DO THIS AND
PUSHED ME EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A SPECIAL
THANKS. AND OF COURSE, TO MY
DEAR, DEAR FRIEND SUSAN. YOU'RE
ALL INCREDIBLE. THANK YOU FOR
THIS, TEN MINUTES OF FAME. AND I
WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY SEES WHO DESERVES THE
15 MINUTES OF FAME PLUS AND THAT
IS ALL THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
THAT HELP US DO OUR JOBS. AND
THAT'S OUR INCREDIBLE STAFF. MR.
PETE, THANK YOU ALSO FOR
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT ME. AND IT
MEANS THE WORLD TO ME, YOU AND
YOUR STAFF. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. CONGRATULATIONS,
SENATOR ATKINS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT UP FOR
RECOGNITION WILL BE SENATOR
DALLY FROM DISTRICT ONE. AND
JOINING HIM TODAY IS HIS FAMILY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, MEGAN DALLY.
HIS SON, CHASE DALLY, THE
ELDEST, REAGAN DALLY AND MY
CARTWHEEL BUDDY, ROSLYN DALLY.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. FIRST UP, TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR DALLY WILL BE SENATOR
EGGMAN.
OKAY. AND I FORGOT ONE MORE.
LOGAN HAS THE FANTASTIC LEDGE.
DIRECTOR. I'LL KEEP COMING BACK.
ASKED ME TO SPEAK AGAIN, BUT
RIGHT NOW I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
MY FRIEND BRIAN DALLY, BRIAN AND
I CAME IN TOGETHER IN 2012, WE
HAVE SPENT THESE LAST 12 YEARS
TOGETHER AND INSTANTLY HIT IT
OFF. I THINK WE SAW IN EACH
OTHER THE SAME KIND OF TRYING TO
LEAD WITH COMMON SENSE, TRYING
TO LET PEOPLE SEE YOUR HEART.
DON'T THINK YOU'RE TOO SMART AND
NOT BE AFRAID OF HARD WORK, WHEN
I, WHEN I FIRST GOT HERE, ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS BRIAN DID IS
INVITES EVERYBODY UP AND I WAS
ABLE TO GO AND MEET HIS LOVELY
FAMILY MORE THAN ONCE. I WAS
INVITED INTO THE DALLY HOME ONCE
DURING A FOREST FIRE, WHEN THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS WAS OUT FLY
FISHING AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
THERE WAS A FIRE, THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS HAD TO EVACUATE OUT OF
THAT RIVER, AND WE COULDN'T GO
BACK DOWN. WE HAD TO GO UP. AND
SO THE DALLIES INVITED US TO
THEIR HOME, OPENED THEIR HOME,
AND WE ALL HAD A GIANT
SLEEPOVER. SO THANK YOU TO THOSE
DALLIES AND THESE HERE, I THINK
SOME I THINK SOME MEMBERS SLEPT
IN TEENAGE BOYS ROOM AND IT WAS
KIND OF FUNNY, BRIAN, WILL TELL
YOU HE DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE,
JUST A FARMER. BUT I'LL TELL
YOU, THERE'S NOT A SMARTER
PERSON ON THIS FLOOR, THAN BRIAN
DALLY, BECAUSE HE'S GOT A
NATURAL CURIOSITY. HE ALWAYS
WANTS TO UNDERSTAND. HE ALWAYS
WANTS TO LEARN MORE, AND HE
ALWAYS WANTS TO IF HE CAN BE A
FRIEND. BRIAN DALLY IS ALSO A
MAN OF HUGE FAITH, AND HE IS THE
KIND OF GUY WHO IS A PERSON OF
FAITH WHO HE DOESN'T TELL YOU
ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME. HE NEVER
TALKS ABOUT IT. HE LIVES IT. YOU
SEE IT. YOU SEE IT IN HOW HE
CARRIES HIMSELF. YOU SEE IT IN
HOW HE LOVES HIS FAMILY. YOU SEE
IT ON HOW HE SERVES HIS
CONSTITUENTS. HE LIVES THE WORD
OF GOD. HE LIVES THE WORD OF GOD
TO LOVE THE OTHER AND TO LOVE
GOD AND TO LOVE OUR LAND. RIGHT?
HIS FAMILY CAME HERE AS, I WAS
GOING TO SAY, SHARECROPPERS.
THAT'S TONY NØ. THEY CAME HERE
AS HOMESTEADERS TO GET A STAKE
OF LAND. AND BRIAN HAS KEPT THAT
DREAM ALIVE WITH THAT STAKE OF
LAND. AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
BETTER AND ALL UNDERSTAND
FARMING A LITTLE BIT MORE,
BECAUSE HE TELLS ABOUT US ALL
THE TIME. HE'S PROBABLY AS
FAMOUS FOR HIS FLOOR SPEECHES AS
I AM, BUT IN A DIFFERENT KIND OF
WAY. BUT IT'S THAT SAME THING
TRYING TO MAKE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
RURAL CALIFORNIA TAKES UP ALMOST
THE ENTIRE STATE, BUT THEY HAVE
THE FEWEST REPRESENTATIVES. AND
BRIAN HAS BEEN A REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THOSE PEOPLE. I'M VERY PROUD
THAT I GET TO SPEAK FOR SOMEBODY
WHO IS GOING TO BE GOVERNOR AND
SPEAK FOR SOMEBODY WHO WAS
ALMOST GOVERNOR, BECAUSE HE TOOK
HIS LOVE OF CALIFORNIA AND
AGRICULTURE AND WHAT HE BELIEVED
IN AND PUT IT, TOOK IT ON THE
ROAD, WENT UP AND DOWN THE STATE
TALKING ABOUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA OF HIS DREAMS. AND WE
DON'T AGREE WITH EACH OTHER ON
POLICY A LOT, ALTHOUGH SOMETIMES
WE DO, BECAUSE WE BOTH BELIEVE
THAT PEOPLE NEED A SHOT. PEOPLE
NEED A FAIR PLAYING FIELD TO BE
ABLE TO DO THEIR VERY BEST. AND
THAT HARD WORK SHOULD PAY OFF. I
HAD AN OCCASION A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO. PEOPLE KNOW I MY BROTHER,
LIKE BRIAN, TALL, HANDSOME,
CHARMING, ALL THOSE THINGS. BUT
UNLIKE BRIAN, I WAS AT AN EVENT
AND THERE WAS TWO WOMEN THERE
WHO SAID, OH, I KNEW, I KNOW
YOUR BROTHER, AND I CRINGE AND I
SAY, I'M SORRY. AND AS I'M
DRIVING HOME, I THINK ABOUT HOW
MY BROTHER AND I ARE SO ALIGNED
IN POLITICS. BUT SOMETIMES OUR
BEHAVIORS DON'T ALWAYS MIRROR
THOSE THINGS. AND I THOUGHT
ABOUT THE PERFECT BROTHER, AND I
THOUGHT ABOUT BRIAN, THAT WE
DON'T SHARE THE SAME POLITICS,
BUT I HONOR HIS VALUES AND HIS
FRIENDSHIP AND HIS COURAGE. WHEN
WE GOT HERE TOGETHER, IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT WE WERE STILL IN THE
BEFORE. IT WAS BEFORE THE METOO.
SO THERE WAS A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WENT WENT ON IN THE EVENING
AND YOU GET TO SEE A LOT. WHEN
WE FIRST GOT HERE, I DON'T KNOW
IF I EVER SAID THIS TO YOU,
MEGAN, BUT, YOU KNOW, I SAW I
SAW A PERSON FROM ACROSS THE
STREET BEING FRIENDLY AND, AND I
SAID, YOU KNOW, AND HE WAS SO
HORRIFIED THAT ANYBODY WOULD
EVEN THINK EVEN THINK THAT HE
HAD LOOKED OUTSIDE HIS MARRIAGE.
HE IMMEDIATELY CHANGED
EVERYTHING ABOUT WHAT COULD
APPEAR, WHAT WAS NOT, BUT COULD
APPEAR TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WASN'T JUST THE APPEARANCE OF
HIM STRAYING FROM HIS FAMILY,
FROM HIS COMMITMENT, FROM HIS
VALUES, WAS SO HORRIFYING TO
HIM. I'LL NEVER FORGET THAT. AND
I'LL NEVER FORGET YOU. MY
BROTHER FROM THE NORTH, STATE OF
JEFFERSON. I LOVE YOU, MAN.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN. NEXT
UP, REPUBLICAN LEADER BRIAN
JONES. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS, I WANT TO FILE AN
OFFICIAL COMPLAINT FOR WHOEVER'S
ASSIGNED THE SPEAKING ORDER THAT
I NEVER WANT TO FOLLOW SENATOR
EGGMAN EVER AGAIN IN A SPEECH OF
ANY KIND. SHE'S HAD SOME
POWERFUL WORDS. THIS YEAR ON THE
FLOOR. AND THANK YOU. I'M VERY
IMPRESSED THAT YOU DID ALL THAT
WITHOUT NOTES AND GOT THROUGH
IT. I'M GOING TO TRY TO DO THIS
WITH NOTES AND STILL GET THROUGH
IT. IT'S AN HONOR, OF COURSE,
WHENEVER YOU'RE ASKED TO SPEAK
ON SOMEBODY'S BEHALF AND
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE THAT
THEY ARE TO YOU, PROFESSIONALLY,
OF COURSE, IS ALWAYS A BIG DEAL.
BUT PERSONALLY IS EVEN A BIGGER
DEAL. AND BRIAN IS A BIG DEAL IN
MY LIFE AND MY FAMILY'S LIFE,
BUT THE REASON HE'S A BIG DEAL
IS BECAUSE OF HIS FAMILY
SUPPORTING HIM AND HELPING HIM
BE A BIG DEAL. I MEAN, FIRST
OFF, ANYBODY NAMED BRIAN HAS GOT
TO BE A PRETTY COOL DUDE IN THE
FIRST PLACE. BUT AS YOU MAY,
SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER, BRIAN
IS THE FOUNDING MEMBER, ONE OF
THE FOUNDING MEMBERS OF THE
BRIAN CAUCUS, WHICH WAS A BIG
DEAL WHEN WE WERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY, BECAUSE NEARLY 20% OF
THE ASSEMBLY REPUBLICANS AT THE
TIME WERE NAMED BRIAN. AND SO WE
THOUGHT WE WERE KIND OF HOTSHOTS
BY STARTING THE BRIAN CAUCUS.
BUT BRIAN HAS ATTACKED AND
TACKLED MANY ISSUES OVER THE
YEARS, AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IMPRESSED ME IMMEDIATELY
WHEN, WHEN BRIAN GOT ELECTED IN
2012. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
WILL REMEMBER THIS, THE CLASS OF
2010, WHICH THE PRO TEM EMERITUS
MYSELF, SENATOR GROVE, I THINK
ARE THE ONLY ONES HERE THAT
NANCY WAS HERE AT THAT TIME. BUT
THOSE OF US THAT GOT ELECTED IN
2010 HAD A PARTICULAR TYPE OF
ATTITUDE. WHEN WE GOT HERE AND
THE CLASS OF 2012 GOT ELECTED
AND CAME IN, I WILL. I THINK I
CAN HONESTLY SAY A BETTER
ATTITUDE, WANTING TO GET THINGS
DONE, WANTING TO WORK, TO BE
COLLABORATIVE. AND BRIAN WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST REPUBLICANS THAT I
GOT TO WATCH, WORK IN THAT
MANNER. AND IMMEDIATELY I COINED
THE PHRASE THE DEMOCRAT
WHISPERER BECAUSE BRIAN WAS ABLE
TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS ACROSS
THE AISLE THAT MANY OF US HAD
TRIED AND STRUGGLED TO DO. BUT
HE ACTUALLY CAME IN AND HE SET
THE EXAMPLE OF HOW TO DO THAT,
HOW TO STAY TRUE TO YOUR
PRINCIPLES, TRUE TO YOUR
POLICIES, TRUE TO YOUR FAITH,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, FIND A WAY
TO BE EFFECTIVE AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE NOT JUST FOR HIS
DISTRICT, BUT FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE. I THINK BRIAN DID THAT.
JUST A FEW OF THE ISSUES THAT
BRIAN WORKED ON ARE RURAL
BROADBAND, AGRICULTURE, HEALTH
CARE, WATER TRANSPORTATION,
WATER AND TRANSPORTATION,
WILDFIRE, WILDFIRE PREVENTION,
ENERGY, AND THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON. NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THOSE IS
A SOFTBALL. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM. BIG IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
BRIAN CHAMPIONED AND TOOK ON. HE
REPRESENTS, I THINK THE LARGEST
SENATE DISTRICT IN THE STATE. HE
HAS DOZENS OF COUNTIES COVERING
A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF CALIFORNIA,
RANGING FROM HAPPY CAMP TO GOOSE
LAKE TO PEACEFUL PINES TO NEARBY
FOLSOM, FROM ROCKLIN TO WHITNEY
RANCH. AND EVERY POINT IN
BETWEEN HE HAS SERVED HIS
CONSTITUENT PROUDLY FOR FIVE
YEARS IN THE SENATE AND SEVEN
YEARS IN THE ASSEMBLY. BEFORE
THAT, HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
LASSEN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND REELECTED THREE
TIMES. AS WE ALL KNOW, BRIAN
BEGAN AS A STATE. BEING A STATE
LEGISLATOR CAN BE A TOUGH JOB.
SERVING IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
REALLY TOUGH. AND BRIAN DID IT
FOR 16 YEARS BEFORE JOINING US
HERE IN SACRAMENTO TO HELP US
FIX CALIFORNIA SENATOR DAHLE. AS
WE ALL KNOW, IS A BIG SUPPORTER
OF FFA. FUTURE FARMERS OF
AMERICA, AND I'M SURE THAT
THERE'S LOTS OF GOOD STORIES
ABOUT HIM SUPPORTING YOUNG
FARMERS AND YOUNG RANCHERS AND
STATE FAIRS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT. AND HE HAD LOTS OF GREAT
HEADLINES WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR. I THINK THERE WAS
ONE A COUPLE OF STORIES THAT
WERE TOLD WHILE HE WAS GOVERNOR
AND HEADLINES HE WOULD HAVE
RATHER DONE WITHOUT WHEN IT WAS
DEALING WITH SUPPORTING FUTURE,
YOUNG FOLKS COMING UP IN THE
FARMING. I'LL LET YOU ALL LOOK
THAT UP FOR YOURSELVES. WE ALL
KNOW HE STRONGLY SUPPORTS
FOUR-H, WHICH IS A HAVE THIS IN
THE RIGHT ORDER HEAD, HEART,
HANDS AND HEALTH. BUT SENATOR
DAHLE IS ALSO A SUPPORTER OF THE
FOUR F'S. YES, THE FOUR F'S.
FAITH AS SENATOR EGGMAN RIGHTLY
POINTED OUT VERY CLEARLY, HE
SERVES GOD AND DEMONSTRATES
EVERY DAY HIS UNWAVERING SUPPORT
FOR THE RIGHT OF ALL OTHERS TO
BELIEVE AND PRACTICE THEIR OWN
FAITH AND RELIGION. AND WHEN I
THINK OF BRIAN IN MY PERSONAL
LIFE, I THINK OF PROVERBS 2717
AS IRON SHARPENS AN IRON, A MAN
SHARPENS THE COUNTENANCE OF HIS
FRIEND. AND I THINK I CAN SAY I
KNOW FOR MYSELF, BUT I THINK FOR
BOTH OF US, THAT THERE HAS BEEN
MANY TIMES THAT, AS IRON HAS
SHARPENED IRON, WE HAVE
STRENGTHENED, SHARPEN THE
COUNTENANCE OF EACH OTHER.
SOMETIMES, IN AGREEMENT. BUT
THAT SHARPNESS COMES IN
DISAGREEMENT WHEN YOU CAN WORK
THEM OUT, SPEAK IT OUT, TALK IT
OUT, WALK IT OUT, AND AT THE END
OF THAT EXPERIENCE, COME TO AN
AGREEMENT AND WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE.
FAMILY OF WHICH BRIAN'S STRONGLY
LOVES, WHO ARE ALL HERE TODAY
AND ARE THE BACKBONE OF BRIAN'S
LIFE AND HIS SERVICE. NOT NOT
HERE IN THE STATE, BUT HIS
ENTIRE LIFE. THE HIS HARD
WORKING STAFF. YOU KNOW, ONE OF
THE THINGS I BELIEVE AFTER BEING
HERE FOR AS MANY YEARS AS I'VE
BEEN THAT YOU CAN HOW YOU JUDGE
A FELLOW MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE OR ANY PERSON
ACTUALLY IS THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEIR STAFF. AND IF YOU
WATCH BRIAN'S STAFF, FROM THE
MOMENT HE GOT HERE TO THE MOMENT
THAT HE'S LEAVING, HE HAS SOME
OF THE HARDEST WORKING, MOST
LOYAL. I BELIEVE SOME OF THEM,
IF THEY HAD TO, WOULD WALK
THROUGH SNOW FROM THE CAPITOL TO
BIEBER FOR HIM. IF THERE WAS, IF
THERE WAS A TASK THAT NEEDED TO
BE DONE AND THEY KNEW IT WAS FOR
THE BETTER GOOD FREEDOM. NOBODY
CAN MAKE A MORE PERSUASIVE
ARGUMENT THAN BRIAN FOR THE
ABSOLUTE NEED TO PROTECT FREEDOM
FOR AMERICANS, PARTICULARLY THE
PLIGHT OF FAMILY FARMERS AND
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS, HIS HEART
AND THOUGHTS ARE ALWAYS WITH THE
STRUGGLING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
DISAPPEARING FAMILY FARMERS.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE IMPASSIONED
PLEAS ON THIS FLOOR THAT I KNOW
HAS MOVED VOTES. I KNOW IT HAS.
MAYBE NOT ON THE FLOOR EVERY
SINGLE TIME, BUT I KNOW IN
COMMITTEE AND I KNOW BEHIND THE
SCENES AND I KNOW AS MEMBERS ARE
TALKING TO FOLKS AT DIFFERENT
EVENTS, YOU'RE IMPASSIONED PLEAS
HAVE MADE A DIFFERENCE, AND THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AND THAT WILL BE
PART OF YOUR LEGACY. THE FOURTH
F IS FOR FRIENDSHIP. THERE'S NO
BETTER FRIEND TO HAVE THAN BRIAN
DOOLEY. IT IS THROUGH THICK AND
THIN FOR HIS FRIENDS WHICH KNOW
NO BOUNDARIES, INCLUDING
POLITICS. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, I WOULD
IMPLORE YOU TO LOOK AT THE
EXAMPLE OF SENATOR DASCHLE AND
SENATOR EGGMAN, SENATOR GROVE
AND SENATOR ATKINS AS THE
EXAMPLE THAT WE SHOULD ALL
ASPIRE TO OF HAVING A FRIENDSHIP
THAT IS MEANINGFUL IN THIS
BUILDING AND NOT JUST IN THIS
BUILDING, BUT THOSE FRIENDSHIPS
HAVE AN IMPACT AND AN EVER
LASTING LEGACY ON THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA. FROM THIS DAY,
MOVING FORWARD. IT IS A PERSONAL
GOAL OF MINE TO BUILD THOSE KIND
OF RELATIONSHIPS AND FOLLOW THAT
EXAMPLE FOR MY FRIENDS. HE IS
LITERALLY THE POSTER PERSON FOR
AGREE TO DISAGREE, BUT DON'T BE
DISAGREEABLE. BRIAN, MEGAN AND
THEIR FAMILY HAVE HOSTED OVER
140 LEGISLATORS FROM BOTH
PARTIES TO THEIR HOUSE IN
BIEBER, CALIFORNIA. WHERE IS
BIEBER, CALIFORNIA? I MEAN, WHO
EVER HEARD OF BIEBER CALIFORNIA?
I TALKED TO PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT ABOUT JUSTIN BIEBER.
WHY DOES JUSTIN BIEBER HAVE A
TOWN IN CALIFORNIA? 300 PEOPLE,
217. AND MY FAMILY HAS STAYED IN
THOSE TEENAGE BEDROOMS. ALSO ONE
OF THE THINGS I PRIDE IN MY KIDS
IS ALL THREE OF MY KIDS KNOW HOW
TO DRIVE A STICK SHIFT. I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF TEACHING MY
OLDER TWO. HE HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF TEACHING MY YOUNGEST ONE HOW
TO DRIVE HIS BIG F. NO, NOT.
IT'S A BIG DODGE. SO WHICH IS
WHOLLY DIFFERENT. TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THAN DRIVING A SMALL
LITTLE JEEP. HE WAS AND STILL IS
LIKE A CHILD ON CHRISTMAS
MORNING WHEN HE'S ABOUT TO
FINALIZE A BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT
ON SOMETHING BY WORKING ACROSS
THE AISLE FOR THE COMMON GOOD.
WHEN BRIAN DALLY WASN'T WORKING
FOR CALIFORNIA IN HIS DISTRICT,
IN COMMITTEE OR ON THIS FLOOR,
HE WAS HOSTING WILD GAME FEEDS
OR HIS ANNUAL PEACH
DISTRIBUTION, WHICH WE GOT TO
ENJOY YESTERDAY. AS A FORMER ONE
OF THE FORMER LEADERS IN OUR
CAUCUS, BRIAN HAS BEEN A SOURCE
OF MUCH WISDOM AND ADVICE, WHICH
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE. AND PART
OF THAT IRON SHARPENING IRON IN
2022, AS WE'VE ALREADY HEARD,
BRIAN STEPPED UP AND CARRIED THE
REPUBLICAN FLAG IN THE RACE FOR
GOVERNOR AGAINST A WELL-FUNDED
INCUMBENT. MANY OF YOU MAY NOT
KNOW THIS, THOUGH. BRIAN CARRIED
A MAJORITY OF COUNTIES 33 OUT OF
58, AND WON MORE SENATE SEATS
AND MORE AND MORE CONGRESSIONAL
SEATS THAN THE MEMBERS RUNNING
IN THOSE SEATS. SO HE SET THE
EXAMPLE FOR REPUBLICANS ON HOW
TO WIN OVER 40% OF VOTERS. FOUR
OUT OF TEN CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WANTED HIM
TO BE GOVERNOR BACK IN NOVEMBER
2022. AND I'LL JUST, TAKE A TAKE
A GUESS HERE THAT THERE'S
PROBABLY EVEN MORE THAT WOULD
LIKE FOR HIM TO BE GOVERNOR
TODAY. I'LL JUST LEAVE IT AT
THAT. SENATOR DAHLE, I'M GOING
TO MISS YOU. YOU ARE A BROTHER.
YOU'RE MY OLDER BROTHER. AND
I'VE ALWAYS NEEDED AN OLDER
BROTHER. YOU JUST ASK MY MOM.
AND I KNOW THAT, OUR FRIENDSHIP
IS GOING TO LAST THE TIME AND
WHEN WE BOTH DEPART FROM HERE,
OUR FRIENDSHIP IS GENUINE AND
REAL. AND WILL CONTINUE. AND
I'LL LOOK FORWARD TO HOSTING YOU
DOWN IN MY DISTRICT, AT MY HOME,
AT SOME POINT IN TIME. THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MY DISTRICT
AND HIS DISTRICT IS THERE'S LOTS
OF COOL PLACES TO STAY IN MY
DISTRICT. THE ONLY COOL PLACE TO
STAY IN HIS DISTRICT IS HIS
HOUSE. SO, MEMBERS, I'M REALLY
GOING TO MISS SENATOR DALLY, BUT
WE HAVE A NEW SENATOR DALLY
COMING IN IN DECEMBER. I
BELIEVE. AND THE NEW DALLY WILL
EVEN BE BETTER THAN THE OLD
DALLY WHEN SHE GETS HERE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE HELP ME.
THANK SENATOR DALLY FOR HIS
SERVICE TO OUR STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, SENATOR
JONES. SENATOR DALLY, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. WELL, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, MY FRIENDS, FOR
SPEAKING. FIRST, I WANT TO AND
FOREMOST, I WANT TO I WANT TO
THANK GOD FOR, BLESSING ME WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE THE
NORTH STATE, FOR THE PAST 12
YEARS, I AM DEEPLY HUMBLED. AND
THEN I WANT TO TALK ABOUT. MEGAN
YOU'RE THE BEST THING THAT EVER
HAPPENED TO ME IN MY LIFE. I
LOVE YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
SAYING YES TO ME. THANK YOU FOR
BEING A GREAT MOM. THANKS FOR
BEING A GREAT ASSEMBLYWOMAN.
THANKS FOR EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE FOR MY LIFE AND FOR
MY FAMILY AND OUR AND OUR
FUTURE. YOU ARE THE ROCK AND I
COULD NOT DO DO ANYTHING WITHOUT
YOU. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING MY PARTNER FOR LIFE. AND I
WANT TO JUST THIS IS GOING TO GO
AWAY FROM MY NOTES BECAUSE I
WANT TO I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT SENATOR EGGMAN RIGHT AT
THIS POINT, BECAUSE A TRUE
FRIEND WILL WILL CHALLENGE YOU
AND QUESTION YOU AND SENATOR
EGGMAN. I WENT OUT AND HAD SOME
BEERS WITH A WITH AN
ENVIRONMENTAL FRIEND OF OURS.
SHE'S OUR FRIEND AND SUSAN HEARD
ABOUT IT AND THOUGHT SOMETHING
WAS UP AND SHE CALLED ME OUT ON
IT AND WE WERE WALKING DOWN THE
STREET. I'LL NEVER FORGET IT.
AND IT WAS THE GREATEST THING
THAT EVER HAPPENED TO ME,
BECAUSE I MADE A RULE THAT DAY
THAT NOTHING GOOD AFTER 1030 AT
NIGHT HAPPENS. AND I WOULD GO
HOME AT 1030 BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT THAT PERCEPTION. AND BUT IT
TOOK A GOOD FRIEND TO TELL ME,
HEY, THIS IS THE PERCEPTION. AND
SO, SUSAN, I TOLD MY SON ABOUT
THAT THE OTHER NIGHT WHEN I WAS
TALKING ABOUT YOU. SO I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A LITTLE SIDEBAR
AND NOW I WANT TO. MEGAN, I LOVE
YOU. YOU'RE THE ROCK CHASE. YOU
WERE 12 YEARS OLD WHEN WE
STARTED, AND YOU'RE 24 TODAY.
YOU HAVE STEPPED UP TO BE A MAN.
I AM SO PROUD OF YOU. YOU ARE
RUNNING OUR BUSINESS. YOU'RE
RUNNING OUR FARM. YOU'RE TAKING
ON THE GENERATIONS OF DOLLIES
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY STILL BE ON
THAT LAND. AND I APPRECIATE YOU
SO MUCH. YOU ARE UNBELIEVABLY A
WONDERFUL HUMAN BEING. REAGAN.
ONE YEAR OF YOUR LIFE, YOU
SUBSTITUTED FOR TO RUN FOR
GOVERNOR FOR ME AND SPENT THE
WHOLE TIME ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
WITH ME AND I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
AND YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO
YOU'RE GOING TO BE IN THIS GAME
SOMEDAY. I BELIEVE. I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO DO THAT, BUT
I BELIEVE YOU'LL BE PART OF THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE YOU NEED TO BE,
QUITE FRANKLY, AND YOU'LL BE A
THOUSAND TIMES BETTER THAN I AM.
NOW, ROZ. 12 YEARS AGO, WE WERE
AT CHICKAREE, WALKING ACROSS THE
STREET. YOU WERE THREE, AND I
WAS HOLDING YOUR HAND. AND YOU
SAID TO ME, DADDY, IS THAT YOUR
CASTLE? AND I SAID, YES, THAT'S
WHERE I'M GOING TO GO TO WORK.
HERE YOU ARE NOW A WOMAN. I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY THOUSANDS,
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MILES
YOU'VE RIDDEN IN A CAR BACK AND
FORTH TO BEAVER, AND YOU ARE
WISER THAN YOUR YEARS. I'M SORRY
THAT THERE WAS TIMES WHEN YOU
HAD TO DEAL WITH YOUR DAD
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR AND HAVING
TO PUT UP WITH THAT AT SCHOOL
AND RIDICULED AND ALL THE
THINGS. BUT YOU'RE BETTER FOR
IT. YOU'LL LIVE THROUGH IT AND
YOU'RE AWESOME. I CAN'T WAIT TO
SEE THE REST OF YOUR STORY. ALL
THREE OF YOU, YOUR STORIES AND
YOUR YOUR HISTORY AND THE AND
THE CHAPTERS THAT YOU'LL DO IN
THIS GREAT STATE. SO THANK YOU
GUYS. I LOVE YOU SO MUCH. NOW TO
THE STAFF, BERNIE, ERICA, ERICA,
I HAVE SOMETHING FOR YOU. YES
IT'S OUR IT'S OUR INSIDE JOKE. I
WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MAKING US ALL LOOK SO GOOD AND
DOING THE HARD WORK BEHIND THE
SCENES. THE SERGEANTS, THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS THAT HAVE
THAT MAKE US SO MUCH BETTER THAT
I'VE BUILT RELATIONSHIPS WITH.
AND I GAVE A SPEECH ON THE
BUDGET AND THEY WERE BACK IN THE
BACK AND THEY WERE THEY WERE
TEARED UP. THEY WERE TEARED UP.
AND THEY SAID, BRIAN, WE'RE
GOING TO MISS YOU. AND I'M LIKE,
I'M GOING TO MISS YOU MORE, AND
I'M GOING TO MISS THE FIGHT. SO
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS, THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS TEAM AND THE
DOLLY TEAM, I SEE I'M NOT GOING
TO NAME THEM OFF BECAUSE
NOBODY'S SPECIAL THAN ANYBODY
ELSE. THEY'RE ALL AMAZING. TO MY
DISTRICT STAFF WHO'S TRAVELED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MILES IN
THIS GIANT DISTRICT TO GO SERVE
SOMEBODY TO MY STAFF, HELPING
OTHER MEMBERS THROUGH THE ED
PROCESS. EVERY ONE OF YOU IS SO
SPECIAL TO ME. I LOVE YOU SO
MUCH. YOU'VE BEEN AMAZING. AND
TO THE STAFF THAT I DON'T HAVE
WORKING FOR ME NOW THAT WORK FOR
OTHER MEMBERS, IT'S AMAZING HOW
MANY SENATE-TV NGUYEN HAS A
CHIEF OF STAFF THAT CAME FROM MY
OFFICE. MY WIFE HAS A CHIEF OF
STAFF THAT CAME FROM. I CAN JUST
TELL YOU, THERE'S MANY PEOPLE
THAT WORKED IN MY OFFICE AND I
LOVE YOU ALL AND I'M SO PROUD TO
SEE YOU GROW AND I EXPECT YOU TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. NOW TO MY
EMPLOYEES AT HOME, I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE CAMERA IS AT, BUT AND
MY NEIGHBORS FOR HARVESTING MY
CROPS, FOR TAKING CARE OF MY
BUSINESS. LESTER SHEPHERD I LOVE
YOU. YOU RUN MY BUSINESS BETTER
THAN I COULD. THEY'RE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE. AND TO THE PEOPLE IN MY
LITTLE TOWN OF BEAVER, THAT
SAID, YES, YOU CAN DO IT. WE ARE
BEHIND YOU. GO TO THE STATE. WE
WILL TAKE CARE OF YOUR LAND. WE
WILL TAKE CARE OF YOUR FAMILY,
ALL THOSE AMAZING PEOPLE. I WANT
TO JUST SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S. I COULD NOT HAVE DONE IT.
I COULD NOT RUN MY BUSINESS AND
BE HERE. AND THEY DID IT FOR ME.
NOW I WANT TO JUST TAKE A SECOND
TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHY I LOVE CALIFORNIA SO MUCH
AND WHY THIS PLACE IS SO
IMPORTANT. MY GRANDFATHER,
DURING THE GREAT DEPRESSION CAME
TO CALIFORNIA LOOKING FOR A JOB.
HE WAS THE SECOND YOUNGEST OF 13
KIDS, AND HE WAS A MACHINIST. HE
GOT SHOT IN THE WAR, WORLD WAR
ONE AND HE WENT TO LÀ COULD NOT
FIND A JOB AND HE ENDED UP UP
NORTH. HE HAD AN UNCLE IN SHASTA
COUNTY THAT HE WENT TO VISIT,
AND HIS UNCLE TOLD HIM, YOU NEED
TO GO TO SISKIYOU COUNTY.
THEY'RE GIVING OUT LAND GRANTS
FOR VETERANS. AND HE WENT AND
PUT HIS NAME IN A PICKLE JAR,
AND THEY DREW HIS NAME OUT. AND
WE GOT AN 80 ACRE HOMESTEAD, 94
YEARS AGO. AND CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN GREAT TO THE DALLES AND TO
CALIFORNIA. AND HE SAID THIS IS
THE PROMISED LAND. THIS IS THE
PLACE. HE WAS MORMON. THE
MORMONS WERE IN UTAH, AND HE
SAID THEY MISSED IT. THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO
WHEN YOU TILL THE LAND AND YOU
THINK ABOUT THE NEXT GENERATION,
THAT WAS MY GRANDFATHER AND MY
DAD. AND NOW ME, AND NOW CHASE
ARE GOING TO TEND THAT LAND. SO
IT'S ABOUT THE NEXT GENERATION.
IT IS WHY I DO WHAT I DO BECAUSE
I WANT A FUTURE FOR MY KIDS. I
WANT A FUTURE FOR YOUR KIDS, AND
I WANT A FUTURE FOR THIS STATE.
IT'S AMAZING. IT'S AN AMAZING
STATE. IT'S BEEN A GREAT RUN TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE WITH ALL OF
YOU. I THANK YOU FOR COMING TO
MY DISTRICT AND UNDERSTANDING,
AND THANK YOU FOR TAKING ME TO
YOUR DISTRICTS AND UNDERSTANDING
AND TELLING ME YOUR STORIES. I
THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE
NEED MORE, THE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT WE'VE BUILT AND LEARNING
WHERE SOME TRY TO WALK IN
SOMEONE ELSE'S SHOES BEFORE YOU
JUDGE WHAT THEY DO. BECAUSE WHEN
YOU DO, YOU'LL UNDERSTAND A LOT
MORE ABOUT THEM. I'VE LEARNED SO
MUCH FROM ALL OF YOU. I TALKED
ABOUT IT WITH SENATOR BRADFORD.
I LEARNED I'VE LEARNED, I'VE
LEARNED DIFFERENT WAYS OF LIFE,
DIFFERENT CULTURES. AND THAT
WEIGHS IN ON HOW THIS AWESOME
STATE IS. IT IS A MELTING POT
LIKE NO OTHER. IT'S ALSO IT HAS
A LOT TO OFFER. AND WE NEED
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY CHALLENGE, BUT
I WANT TO JUST SAY TO ALL OF YOU
AND MY FAMILY AND MY DISTRICT
AND MY STAFF, I LOVE YOU ALL,
AND I'M THE TERM IS UP, BUT THE
WORK STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
I WILL BE DOING SOME WORK IN, IN
MAKING THIS STATE A GREAT STATE.
SO THANK YOU ALL. I APPRECIATE
IT. CONGRATULATIONS, SENATOR
VALLEY, FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK
YOU.
NEXT UP FOR RECOGNITION IS
SENATOR ROTH FROM THE 31ST
DISTRICT. JOINING HIM TODAY IS
HIS LOVELY WIFE, CINDY ROTH.
LET'S GIVE HER A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE. SAY, WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. AND
FIRST UP, TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
ROTH IS SENATOR ATKINS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I AM JUST SO
INCREDIBLY HONORED TO GET TO
SPEAK AND PAY TRIBUTE TO THE
GENERAL, TO SENATOR RICHARD ROTH.
EARLIER THIS MONTH, THE WORLD'S
ATTENTION WAS ON THE OLYMPICS IN
PARIS, FRANCE. ALSO EARLIER THIS
MONTH, THE SENATOR RICHARD
ROTH'S ATTENTION WAS ON THE
SENIOR CENTER IN PARIS,
CALIFORNIA, BECAUSE WHETHER IT'S
SENIORS IN PARIS OR BUSINESSES
IN MORENO VALLEY, STUDENTS AT UC
RIVERSIDE MOBILE HOME OWNERS IN
JURUPA VALLEY, OR HEALTH CARE
EDUCATORS AND PROVIDERS UP AND
DOWN THE INLAND EMPIRE. SENATOR
ROTH ALWAYS PUTS THE PEOPLE OF
HIS DISTRICT FIRST. SENATOR, OUR
DISTRICTS, LIKE UNFORTUNATELY SO
MANY OTHERS, ARE NO STRANGERS TO
THE DEVASTATION OF WILDFIRES.
AND I HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE, AS WE
HONOR YOU TODAY, YOUR SUPPORT
FOR FIRE VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS,
FOR THE FIRST RESPONDERS IN YOUR
DISTRICT, INCLUDING THOSE WHO
PAID THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE IN
PROTECTING OTHERS. SENATOR ROTH
HAS NOT ONLY BEEN THERE FOR HIS
DISTRICT, HE'S ALSO MADE SURE TO
BRING THE DISTRICT HERE TO THE
CAPITOL IN SACRAMENTO. NOW, MY
SCHEDULER, GRACE, TELLS ME WE'VE
PROCESSED MORE THAN 2300
INVITATIONS EVERY YEAR. WHEN I
WAS PRO TEM, AND THAT'S NOT
COUNTING THE NON-STATE REQUEST.
A FEW OF THOSE INVITATIONS WERE
KNOWN AS IMMEDIATE MUST DO'S AND
WENT TO THE TOP OF THE YES PILE.
AND THANKS TO SENATOR ROTH, THE
RIVERSIDE MONDAY MORNING GROUP
WAS ONE OF THEM. I LEARNED SO
MUCH ABOUT RIVERSIDE COUNTY
BECAUSE OF THOSE MEETINGS, AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SENATOR. I DON'T THINK I MISSED
ONE, AND I THINK THAT HOLDS TRUE
FOR MY PREDECESSOR AND MY
SUCCESSOR AS WELL. ALTHOUGH, TO
BE FAIR, I THINK CINDY MAY HAVE
HAD BEEN THE ONE TO BE MORE
PERSUASIVE AS YOU IN DRIVING OUR
ATTENDANCE. THANK YOU. SO
SPEAKING OF CINDY, IT WAS SO
GREAT TO SEE YOU, CINDY AND YOUR
GRANDDAUGHTERS, PAIGE AND PARKER
HERE EARLIER THIS SUMMER. SOME
OF THE BEST STORIES FROM THE
GENERAL WERE WHEN HE WAS ABLE TO
LEAVE AND GO VISIT THE
GRANDDAUGHTERS AND SO WE ALSO
SHARE A LOVE OF OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY AND FOUND THAT WE
ENDED UP IN THE STRANGEST OF
PLACES AT TIMES. LIMA, OHIO.
PARTS OF FLORIDA. SHARING THOSE
STORIES AND THOSE HISTORIES WAS
ALWAYS REALLY A WONDERFUL THING.
I GET THE FEELING NOW THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO BE SPENDING MORE
TIME CLOSER TO HOME IN ANOTHER
ROLE, IN ANOTHER CAPACITY, WHICH
WE THINK IS WONDERFUL,
REPRESENTING YOUR COMMUNITY. AND
IT MIGHT BE PAPA WHO HAS TO
LEARN TO TAKE ORDERS. GENERAL AS
OPPOSED TO GIVING THEM, YOU KNOW,
I ON A PERSONAL, MORE PERSONAL
NOTE, I WILL NEVER FORGET YOUR
REACHING OUT TO ME WHEN I BECAME
THE SPEAKER AND YOU WERE HERE IN
THE SENATE, COMING IN AND
TALKING TO ME AND WELCOMING ME,
THEN TO THE SENATE. YOUR
FRIENDSHIP, YOUR REACHING OUT TO
ME EARLY ON HAS MEANT THE WORLD
TO ME. I APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE
TO COUNTRY. I APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA. I
APPRECIATE YOUR APPROACH TO
ISSUES. AND YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
US ON THIS FLOOR, WE, YOU KNOW,
SOME OF US GET UP AND TALK ON
ISSUES A LITTLE MORE THAN OTHERS.
BUT I GUARANTEE YOU, WHEN THE
GENERAL GETS UP TO SPEAK,
EVERYBODY LISTENS BECAUSE HE
SPEAKS WHEN HE NEEDS TO, WHEN
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND
MANY TIMES WE GET UP TO SPEAK
AND YOU KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO
GO. IT'S PREDETERMINED. WE ALL
KNOW HOW WE FEEL. BUT I HAVE TO
SAY, OF ALL THE FOLKS ON THIS
FLOOR AND THERE ARE SOME
INCREDIBLE COLLEAGUES HERE AND
ORATORS AND SPEAKERS, BUT WHEN
THE GENERAL GETS UP, HE SPEAKS
PLAINLY. HE PUTS IT, PUTS IT
SIMPLY. HE'S BRIEF, HE'S
CONCISE, AND HE SITS DOWN AND
THEN, YOU KNOW, IT IS UPON US TO
LISTEN TO THE WORDS OF WISDOM
UTTERED BY THE GENERAL. I HAVE
BEEN HONORED, SIR, TO SERVE WITH
YOU. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FRIENDSHIP. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COUNSEL. I THANK YOU FOR BEING
WILLING TO TAKE THE HELM OF SOME
COMMITTEES WHEN I HAD TO
CONVINCE YOU TO DO THIS, AND YOU
REMINDED ME EACH AND EVERY TIME
I AM HERE TO DO A, B, AND C NOW,
IF WHAT YOU WANT ME TO DO ALIGNS
WITH A, B AND C, I AM HERE TO
SERVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE. WE ARE ALL BETTER
BECAUSE OF YOUR COUNSEL, OF YOUR
SERVICE, AND I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
YOU TACKLING THINGS BACK HOME AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. GENERAL ROTH
THANK YOU, SENATOR ATKINS. NEXT
UP IS PRESIDENT PRO TEM MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO STAND
TODAY. MEMBERS, EVERY TIME THE
SENATE MEETS WE DO SO UNDER A
MOTTO INSPIRED BY ANCIENT ROME,
WHICH ALSO HAD A PRETTY GOOD
SYNOD AS WELL. ANCIENT ROME HAD
A PRACTICE THAT WE FOLLOW RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THAT
PRACTICE IS AT TIMES THEY SENT
THEIR WISEST GENERALS TO THE
SENATE IN CALIFORNIA IS SO LUCKY
THAT THEY SENT SUCH AN
ACCOMPLISHED MILITARY MAN, A
GENERAL, TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. WE ARE SO GRATEFUL TO BE
ABLE TO HONOR SENATOR ROTH
TODAY. HE'S A FRIEND AND A
COLLEAGUE. AND NO ONE, NO ONE
HAS DONE MORE FOR RIVERSIDE THAN
SENATOR RICHARD ROTH. HE IS
ALWAYS LOYAL. HE IS NEVER AFRAID
TO TACKLE THE TOUGH ISSUES.
SPEAKING OF TOUGH, HE IS TOUGH
AS NAILS. HE IS THE PERSON THAT
YOU WANT BY YOUR SIDE IN THE
DARKEST OF DAYS, SENATOR ROTH
HAS BROUGHT DISCIPLINE, FOCUS
AND ORGANIZATION TO HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THE SENATE, THE
SAME THAT HE DISPLAYED WEARING A
UNIFORM REPRESENTING THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND HIS
LEADERSHIP AND CARE FOR PEOPLE
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE AND THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA, HAS BEEN
NOTHING LESS THAN TREMENDOUS.
SENATOR ROTH REPRESENTS AN AREA
THAT IS GROWING IN POPULATION,
INDUSTRY AND INFLUENCE, AND HE
HAS BEEN RIGHT THERE EVERY STEP
OF THE WAY, MOVING THE INLAND
EMPIRE INTO THE FUTURE. THIS IS
HIS MISSION ALWAYS. AND LET'S BE
CLEAR, THE INLAND EMPIRE IS
GOING TO BE FOREVER HEALTHIER
BECAUSE OF HIS WORK. YOU KNOW,
SENATOR ROTH IS DOING AMAZING
JOB HELPING SOLVE THE NURSING
SHORTAGE IN OUR STATE, WHICH
HE'S DONE IN A BIPARTISAN
APPROACH. HE'S BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR UC RIVERSIDE, HELPING IT
GROW FROM ONE OF THE NEWEST
CAMPUSES IN THE UC SYSTEM TO
NOW, ONE OF THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST WILL CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT OUR REGION AND OUR STATE
FOR DECADES TO COME. NEXT YEAR
IS A SPECIAL YEAR FOR GENERAL
ROTH AND FOR OUR STATE. 2025
WILL BE THE GOLDEN ANNIVERSARY
OF A YOUNG MAN NAMED RICHARD
ROTH, WHO ORIGINALLY ENTERED
ACTIVE DUTY IN THE UNITED STATES
AIR FORCE A HALF CENTURY AGO.
HIS CHOICE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF THE GOLDEN STATE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA FOR
HALF A CENTURY, IS A GIFT. IT IS
A GIFT FOR ALL OF US. AND
SENATOR, IT IS A GIFT FOR
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. YOU ARE TRULY
ONE OF THE BEST. YOUR KIND, YOUR
THOUGHTFUL AND YOUR ALWAYS
PEOPLE DRIVEN. WE ARE SO HAPPY
THAT CINDY IS HERE. YOU'RE AN
AMAZING GRANDPA. WE ARE GOING TO
MISS YOU AND WE KNOW THAT THE
BEST DAYS OF WHAT SENATOR ROTH
DOES FOR THE STATE AND FOR THE
EMPIRE IS STILL AHEAD. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE IT UP LOUD AND PROUD
FOR THE ONE THE ONLY GENERAL,
SENATOR RICHARD ROTH. THANK YOU.
MR. TIÂU. GENERAL ROTH, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MR. PRO TEM AND MADAM
PRO TEM EMERITA. THANK YOU FOR
THOSE KIND REMARKS. AS YOU KNOW,
I TRIED NOT TO SPEAK TODAY, BUT
I GUESS IT'S NOW MY TURN. YOU
KNOW, A FEW WEEKS AGO, I WAS
SITTING AT HOME WATCHING THE
PARIS OLYMPICS, THE INCREDIBLE
PERFORMANCE OF THOSE OLYMPIANS,
BOTH FROM THIS COUNTRY AND OTHER
COUNTRIES. AND I WONDERED WHAT
IT WOULD BE LIKE TO BE ON AN
OLYMPIC TEAM. DO YOU EVER WONDER
THAT? WELL YESTERDAY I WAS
SITTING ON THIS FLOOR AND I WAS
WATCHING THE RECOGNITIONS, AND I
WAS THINKING ABOUT MY SERVICE
WITH YOU ON THE RED CARPET, AND
IT SUDDENLY DAWNED ON ME THAT
FOR 12 YEARS I'VE BEEN
SURROUNDED BY A TEAM OF
OLYMPIANS, DIFFERENT TYPE POLICY
OLYMPIANS, BUT OLYMPIANS
NONETHELESS. YOU KNOW, WHEN I
FIRST CAME UP HERE IN 2012,
NEVER HAVING SERVED AS AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL BEFORE, I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I WAS GOING TO
GET. I DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER IT
WAS FORREST GUMP'S PROVERBIAL
BOX OF CHOCOLATES OR SOMETHING
ELSE. BUT WHAT I FOUND WAS A
GROUP OF THE BRIGHTEST, HARDEST
WORKING, MOST FOCUSED, MOST
PRINCIPLED INDIVIDUALS THAT I
HAVE EVER WORKED WITH IN ANY OF
THE CAREERS THAT I'VE HAD IN, AS
THE PRO TEM SAID, MY RATHER LONG
YEARS ON THIS EARTH ABSOLUTELY,
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE. AND YOU
ACCEPTED ME FOR WHAT I WAS AND
AM, AND YOU AND YOUR
PREDECESSORS ACCEPTED ME FOR
WHERE I COME FROM. AND YOU
ALLOWED ME TO JOIN THIS VERY,
VERY SPECIAL SENATE TEAM. AND
SINCE THAT TIME, I'VE WATCHED
THIS SENATE TEAM SHOOT FOR THE
GOLD TIME AFTER TIME ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE, MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT HITTING THE MARK. AND I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT I AM VERY,
VERY, VERY PROUD TO CALL MYSELF
YOUR TEAMMATE. YOU KNOW, SINCE I
GOT HERE, I'VE TRIED TO WORK
VERY HARD, FRANKLY, JUST TO KEEP
UP WITH YOU, AND I HOPE I'VE
MADE A DIFFERENCE. I GUESS I'LL
LEAVE THAT FOR SOMEONE ELSE TO
JUDGE. BUT I DO KNOW THIS.
YOU'VE MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE IN
MY LIFE. AND THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT I REPRESENT. YOU'VE CHANGED
OUR LIVES. WHEN I BEFORE I CAME
UP HERE, ACTUALLY, OUR, TOLD
SOME OF YOU THIS BEFORE OUR HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WAS ABOUT 78%.
AND OUR COLLEGE GOING RATE WAS
LOWER. FRANKLY, MUCH LOWER THAN
THAT. WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
DOCTORS, WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
NURSES. WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. WE
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH CLINICS, AND
WE DIDN'T HAVE A MEDICAL SCHOOL.
AND ABOUT 21% OF THE PEOPLE
WHERE I COME FROM DIDN'T HAVE
ANY HEALTH INSURANCE AT ALL. ANY
HEALTH INSURANCE AT ALL. WE WERE
UNDER-RESOURCED AND UNDERSERVED.
AND FRANKLY, I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY CARED. LEAST THAT WAS
OUR PERCEPTION UNTIL YOU ALL AND
YOUR PREDECESSORS TOOK NOTICE.
TODAY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY, OUR
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION RATE IS
WELL ABOVE 90%, AND OUR COLLEGE
GOING RATE ISN'T FAR BEHIND.
LESS THAN 7% OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHERE I COME FROM LACK HEALTH
INSURANCE NOW. AND SOME OF THAT
IS BECAUSE THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
HAVE IT. WE HAVE MORE DOCTORS,
WE HAVE MORE NURSES, WE HAVE
MORE ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. WE HAVE MORE
CLINICS, AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
MEDICAL SCHOOLS, PLURAL. WHERE I
COME FROM, CINDY AND I WILL BE
GOING HOME TO A MUCH, MUCH
BETTER PLACE THANKS TO YOU AND
THE AMAZING, AMAZING SENATE
STAFF. WE HAVE IN THIS BUILDING.
AND SPEAKING OF STAFF, I GUESS I
SHOULD GIVE SOME THANKS TO MADAM
SECRETARY AND TO BERNIE AND THE
DESK STAFF AND ALL THE STAFF IN
THIS BUILDING, AND THE STAFF IN
THE Þ STREET BUILDING. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR GUIDING ME AND
ALLOWING ME TO SURVIVE AND
THRIVE FOR THE MOST PART IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT TO MY CAPITOL OFFICE
STAFF AND MY DISTRICT STAFF. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE HARD
WORK AND THE DILIGENCE, AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING MY
BACK. AND FRANKLY, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING UP WITH ME.
AND TO MY COMMITTEE STAFF, YOU
KNOW, IF YOU'VE BEEN HERE LONG
ENOUGH, YOU GET THE CHAIR OF
COMMITTEES. AND I'VE CHAIRED
ABOUT SIX OF THEM, POLICY
COMMITTEES AND BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES OVER MY TIME HERE.
AND TO EACH OF YOU, COMMITTEE
STAFFERS, I JUST WANT TO SAY
YOU'RE AWESOME. AND FOR EVERY
DAY THAT YOU THOUGHT WAS YOUR
WORST DAY AND YOUR WORST
PERFORMANCE, I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
IN ALL THE CAREERS I'VE HAD,
IT'S THE BEST I'VE EVER HAD.
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU'VE RECOGNIZED
CINDY. HOPEFULLY YOU'VE ALL MET
HER. SHE'S THE ONE WHO MADE ME
GET UP EVERY DAY, PACK UP, GET
ON THE AIRPLANE AND COME BACK TO
YOU WHETHER OR NOT I WANTED TO
OR NOT. SHE'S HAD MY BACK FOR
DECADES, AND I OWE HER A LOT. I
LOVE YOU, SWEETIE. WE'RE GOING
HOME SOON. IT'S, BEEN AN HONOR
AND A PRIVILEGE TO SERVE WITH
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU ON
THIS RED CARPET. OBVIOUSLY, THE
PRIVILEGE WILL END SOON, BUT THE
HONOR WILL REMAIN WITH ME FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE,
SENATOR ROCK.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, IT IS NOW
THE DEAN OF NAPA, SENATOR DODD
AND HE'LL BE FIRST RECOGNIZED BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, IT'S MY
DISTINCT PLEASURE TO RISE TODAY
TO PAY TRIBUTE TO A REALLY DEAR
FRIEND, COLLEAGUE, GENTLEMAN AND
A CONNOISSEUR OF FINE LIVING.
THE ONE AND ONLY SENATOR WILLIAM
HAROLD DODD, REPRESENTING NAPA
VALLEY AND THE NORTHERN SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. SENATOR BILL
DODD IS A HOMEBOY. IF YOU WILL.
HE'S A FIFTH GENERATION
CALIFORNIAN, AND HE WAS BORN AND
RAISED ON A SMALL FAMILY FARM IN
NAPA VALLEY. HIS ROOTS IN THE
VALLEY GO DEEP, AND HE CARRIES A
SPECIAL LOVE FOR THAT VALLEY.
HE'S A WILDCAT FROM CHICO STATE.
NONE OF THAT WILL SURPRISE YOU.
WHERE HE GRADUATED AND THEN
SETTLED BACK IN NAPA, WHERE HE
STARTED HIS OWN BUSINESS.
SENATOR DODD BECAME THE ORIGINAL
CULLIGAN MAN. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE A SPECIAL GENERATION
THAT REMEMBER THAT COMMERCIAL
SENATOR BILL DODD STARTED HIS 25
YEAR POLITICAL CAREER AS A
SUPERVISOR ON THE NAPA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, AND HE WAS
SO POPULAR THAT HE WAS ELECTED
FOUR TIMES. AFTER THAT, HE SPENT
TWO YEARS IN THE ASSEMBLY BEFORE
HE ARRIVED HERE IN THE STATE
SENATE, WHERE HE HAS SERVED WITH
DISTINCTION FOR EIGHT YEARS.
DURING SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT, DANGEROUS AND
DEVASTATING YEARS IN HIS
DISTRICT. WE WILL NEVER FORGET
THE WILDFIRES THAT RAVAGED
COMMUNITIES REQUIRED
EVACUATIONS, WHERE FAMILIES LOST
ALL OF THEIR POSSESSIONS,
VINEYARDS AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF ACRES OF GRAPES WERE
DESTROYED, WHICH CAUSED ECONOMIC
DISASTER ON TOP OF THE LIVES
LOST IN THE FIRES AFTERWARDS.
DURING THE RECOVERY PROCESS,
WHEN THE REALITY OF THE FIRE
DAMAGE BECAME APPARENT, THE
REGION ENDURED, DESTROYED WATER
SYSTEMS, CLEANUP OF CONTAMINATED
SOIL WHICH REQUIRED REMEDIATION,
TEMPORARY ELECTRICAL ELECTRICAL
SHUTDOWNS WHICH AFFECTED
BUSINESSES, AND RESIDENTS, AND
COMPOUNDING THE PROBLEM. DELAYS
IN INSURANCE CLAIM AND
SUBSEQUENTLY THE HARDSHIP OF
BEING ABLE TO OBTAIN FIRE
INSURANCE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PROCESS, THE NAPA VALLEY
RECEIVED EXCESS RAIN, WHICH
CAUSED FLOODING, AND FOR A RURAL
COMMUNITY, WATER IS THE
LIFEBLOOD AND A GODSEND. BUT
IT'S A HARDSHIP WHEN WATER COMES
FLOODING IN AFTER A FIRE. THE
TRUE TEST OF CHARACTER OF A
LEGISLATOR IS WHAT THEY DO WHEN
THINGS GET TOUGH. SENATOR BILL
DODD JUMPED INTO ACTION. HE
WORKED ON ISSUES CRITICAL TO HIS
DISTRICT AND TO OUR STATE
INSURANCE REFORM, DISASTER
RELIEF, PLANNED POWER OUTAGES,
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY INSURANCE,
FLOOD CONTROL, WILDFIRE
FORECAST, NATURAL DISASTER
INSURANCE, DEFENSIVE SPACE. ALL
OF THOSE ARE FAMILIAR TO US
BECAUSE SENATOR BILL DODD MADE
IT HIS MISSION TO MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTOOD HOW IMPORTANT THESE
WERE TO HIS DISTRICT, BECAUSE
THE FIRES DIDN'T STAY CONTAINED
TO HIS DISTRICT, ONLY THEY HAVE
RAVAGED THE STATE. BUT SENATOR
DODD WAS AT THE FOREFRONT OF
MAKING SURE THAT WE WERE TAKING
CARE SYSTEMATICALLY OF SOME OF
THESE ISSUES. HE WORKED ON THEM
AND INVITED ALL OF US TO COME
ALONG AND JOIN HIM IN A TOUR OF
HIS DISTRICT TO SEE HOW RECOVERY
WAS COMING ALONG, AND THOSE OF
YOU THAT WENT ALONG ON THOSE
TOURS, REMEMBER HOW HOW HARD HE
WORKED, HOW HE KNEW EVERYBODY ON
THE FRONT LINE AND HOW IMPORTANT
IT WAS TO HIS SOUL THAT WE
REALLY TAKE CARE OF HIS
DISTRICT. SENATOR DODD IS A
COMPASSIONATE, CARING, AND
CONSIDERATE LEADER WHO MAKES
EVERYONE FEEL COMFORTABLE,
THOUGH WE ALSO, ALTHOUGH WE ALSO
ASK TOUGH QUESTIONS AND DOESN'T
TOLERATE ANY BS. HE HAS AUTHORED
114 BILLS IN THE EIGHT YEARS
THAT HE'S BEEN HERE. IN MANY
DIFFERENT POLICY AREAS,
INCLUDING FARMWORKER HOUSING,
WILLIAMSON, WILLIAMSON, ACT,
ELDER, INDEPENDENT ADULT STUDENT
NUTRITION AND AGRICULTURE, WHILE
WHILE IN THE SENATE, SENATOR
DODD HAS SERVED AS A CHAIRMAN OF
THE SENATE GOVERNMENT.
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE FOR THE
PAST SEVEN YEARS. A PERFECT
COMMITTEE FOR A GENTLEMAN AND A
SCHOLAR LIKE SENATOR DODD,
BECAUSE HE HAS DIVED IN WITH
CLASS AND GUSTO INTO ALL OF THE
ARCANE DETAILS OF THE VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES WHICH ENCOMPASSED THE
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION
ALCOHOL, GAMBLING AND CANNABIS.
AND, YOU KNOW, HE'S BEEN A
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE OF ALL
THREE. AND YOU KNOW WHAT HIS
OPINION IS ON THESE ISSUES AS
WELL. SENATOR DODD HAS ALSO
ALWAYS GRACIOUSLY SERVED AS A
BIPARTISAN HOST FOR ALL THE
SENATORS. AND SO IF YOU DIDN'T
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
INVITATION, MY FRIENDS, YOU
MISSED IT. HE HAD HE HAS INVITED
US TO INTIMATE GATHERINGS IN HIS
OFFICE, TO HIS HOME, TAKING
TRIPS OUT TO NAPA VALLEY IN
ORDER TO LEARN AND TASTE EVERY
ASPECT OF HIS DISTRICT. THEY'VE
BEEN FABULOUS, BILL. WE'VE LOVED
IT. WE HOPE YOU KEEP DOING IT
BECAUSE WE GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE A PART OF NAPA THAT NO ONE
ELSE GETS TO SEE. PRIVATE
WINERIES THAT MAKE SOME OF THE
BEST WINES IN THE WORLD QUITE
FRANKLY. SENATOR DODD HAS ALSO
BEEN A GREAT TRAVEL COMPANION.
MY HUSBAND, JUAN, AND I HAVE
REALLY ENJOYED TRAVELING WITH
SENATOR DODD AND HIS WIFE MARY
ON SEVERAL DELEGATIONS, MOST
NOTABLY ON A STUDY TRIP TO
DENMARK. A LOT OF FUN. IN
DENMARK. WE IMMERSED OURSELVES
IN LEARNING ABOUT THEIR CLIMATE
CHANGE SOLUTION, WHICH INCLUDE
OFFSHORE WIND, ELIMINATING TRASH
THROUGH PYROLYSIS, AND
GENERATING RADIANT HEAT USING
BIOFUELS. ALL THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO THEIR SURVIVAL AS A
GREEN COUNTRY. ON THE ON THOSE
TRIPS, SENATOR DODD GREATLY
REPRESENTED HIS THIS INSTITUTION
WITH WITH DISTINCTION AND HELPED
TO BUILD BRIDGES WITH OTHER
NATIONS TO CREATE AN EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS, SOLUTIONS AND
PARTNERSHIPS. AND ON THE FLOOR
AND IN COMMITTEE, I WILL MISS
SENATOR DODD'S INCISIVE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS, ALONG
WITH HIS SHARP WIT. AND THERE IS
NO DOUBT THAT WE WILL ALL
REMEMBER WHAT A DODD I MEANT.
SENATOR DODD'S CHARACTER, GOOD
CHEER AND HARD WORK ON BEHALF OF
HIS DISTRICT HAS HELPED TO BRING
THIS INSTITUTION CLOSER IN A
MANNER THAT HELPS US PERFORM OUR
WORK. WHILE NOT ALIENATING
ANYONE. HIS WIT, SENSE OF
DECORUM, AND ABILITY TO BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER HAS GREATLY
SUPPORTED OUR WORK AND WILL BE
PART OF HIS LEGACY. FINALLY I
WILL SAY THAT I AM GRATEFUL AND
ENJOY THE PRIVILEGE OF A GREAT
FRIENDSHIP WITH SENATOR BILL
DODD AND WILL CONTINUE TO COUNT
ON HIS COUNSEL, SENSE OF HUMOR,
POLICY EXPERTISE, EXPERTISE AND
LOVE OF LIFE. WE LOVE YOU, BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR CABALLERO.
NEXT UP IS PRESIDENT PRO TEM
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TODAY TO SEND OFF ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO HAS WALKED THESE
HALLS WITH THUNDER FOR THE PAST
DECADE. YOU KNOW, BILL DODD IS
SOMEONE WHO I CONSIDER NOT JUST
A COLLEAGUE OR A NEIGHBOR. I
CONSIDER HIM A FRIEND. NAPA
COUNTY HAS BEEN SO INCREDIBLY,
SO INCREDIBLY LUCKY TO HAVE HIS
STEWARDSHIP OVER THE PAST 25
YEARS THAT HE'S DEDICATED HIS
LIFE TO PUBLIC SERVICE, FIRST ON
THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, THE STATE ASSEMBLY,
AND OF COURSE, HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. THE
SENATOR FROM NAPA AND I HAVE A
LOT IN COMMON. WE BOTH GREW UP
IN THE COUNTRY, OUT ON FARMS. WE
ARE DIEHARD LIFELONG GIANTS
FANS. AND I DO APOLOGIZE TO
SENATOR DURAZZO. WE HAVE WORKED
TOGETHER SHARING BOTH LAKE AND
SONOMA COUNTIES FOR OUR ENTIRE
TENURE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND I'M GOING TO GET A LITTLE
CHOKED UP. AND I APOLOGIZE. WE
HAVE, WE ALSO SHARE THE SCARS
FROM MULTIPLE WILDFIRES THAT
HAVE RIPPED THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CANDIDLY BURNED
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES DOWN THE
VALLEY. FIRE. IN 2015, THE TUBBS
FIRE THAT DESTROYED 6300 HOMES
AND MULTIPLE WILDFIRES IN
BETWEEN AND IN THE MIDDLE OF
SUCH DEVASTATION, YOU LEARN WHO
YOU CAN COUNT ON, WHO WILL SHINE
IN OUR DARKEST MOMENTS, WHO WILL
HAVE THE BACK OF THOSE WHO NEED
IT MOST, AND ONE OF THEIR MOST
TRYING TIMES IN LIFE. AND THAT'S
SENATOR BILL DODD. HE HAS PROVED
TO BE THE SOURCE OF RESILIENCE
AND HOPE FOR THOUSANDS WHO LOST
EVERYTHING. SAU HIS TENACIOUS,
WORKED FIRSTHAND ON THE GROUND
IN THE NORTH BAY. TIME AND TIME
AGAIN, HE AND HIS TEAM WERE
RELENTLESS FOR THE COMMUNITY,
ENSURING THAT NO NEED, NO NEED
MET THAT WAS NOT MET FROM
EMERGENCY SHELTER, ENSURING THAT
HOMEOWNERS GOT THE INSURANCE
SETTLEMENTS DUE TO THEM FIGHTING
UNSCRUPULOUS CONTRACTORS, TAKING
ON GREEDY UTILITIES AND NEVER,
NEVER BACKING DOWN FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT HE PROUDLY WORKED
FOR IN HIS SENATE DISTRICT. YOU
KNOW, BILL DODD IS FIERCELY
LOYAL. HE'S COLLABORATIVE. HE'S
A FIGHTER, AND HE'S SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THE JOB THAT HE DOES IS
SO INCREDIBLY PERSONAL TO HIM.
HE WANTS TO BE ABLE TO LEAVE
THIS EARTH BETTER THAN WHERE HE
FOUND IT. HE WANTS TO IMPROVE
HIS HOMETOWN AND BUILD A BETTER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES
TO COME. AND THERE IS NO DOUBT,
AS WE HEARD FROM SENATOR
CABALLERO, THAT THE SENATOR HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY PRODUCTIVE IN
HIS TEN YEARS, TEN YEARS HERE.
YOU HEARD HE'S AUTHORED MORE
THAN 100 BILLS, ONE OF THE MOST
PROLIFIC IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. AND THE REASON
BEING IS HE KNOWS HOW TO BUILD
BRIDGES, BUILD CONSENSUS, AND
GET THE JOB DONE. I WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU,
SENATOR. IT HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH YOU AND WHAT WE CAN SAY
TODAY BECAUSE OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP, CALIFORNIA IS SAFER,
STRONGER, MORE RESILIENT, AND
ALL OF US CAN GET COCKTAILS TO
OUR DOOR. THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF BILL DODD, I WANT
TO END IT RIGHT HERE. YOU KNOW,
BILL DODD IS LOYAL, BUT HE HAS
SOME OF THE MOST LOYAL STAFF ON
EARTH. THEY HAVE BEEN WITH HIM
HIS ENTIRE TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE. HE'S A PROUD PAPA,
A PROUD GRANDAD OF 13 AND A
PROUD HUSBAND TO MARY. I THINK
WE NEED TO TAKE A MOMENT AND SAY
THANK YOU, SENATOR DODD, FOR
YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA. CAN WE PLEASE
GIVE A WARM SENATE? THANK YOU.
TO SENATOR DODD, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. GOD, MY TIME IS FINALLY
HERE. WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I AM
ENTIRELY HONORED BY THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES FROM MERCED.
THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH. AND
FROM OUR PRESIDENT PRO TEM, OR
SHOULD I SAY TODAY, GOVERNOR
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU. YOU'VE BEEN
A GREAT FRIEND AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE GOVERNMENT.
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
FRIENDSHIP OVER THE YEARS. YOU
KNOW, BEING A SENATOR IS ONE OF
THE GREATEST HONORS OF MY LIFE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
WORK HERE ON THIS RED CARPET
WITH EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
IS AN UNPARALLELED TIME IN MY
LIFE. BUT CANDIDLY, IT'S
BITTERSWEET AT THIS MOMENT, AS I
LOOK AT THE END OF THIS, THIS
ROAD, SO TO SPEAK. BUT OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS, HAVE YOU'VE
HEARD WE'VE CONTENDED WITH SOME
PRETTY UNBELIEVABLE ISSUES FROM
WILDFIRE TO THE PANDEMIC. AND
WHILE WE'RE ON THE PANDEMIC AND
FOR SO MANY OTHER REASONS, I
WANT TO THANK THIS GREAT STAFF
THAT WE'VE HAD AND WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO TO LEAD US
THROUGH ALL THESE DIFFERENT
THINGS AND THEIR ABILITY TO
THINK ON THEIR FEET AND REACT
QUICKLY AS THEY DID THAT ONE
DARK NIGHT, AS WE ALL WERE IN
HERE. I SAY, WE BECAUSE, LIKE IT
OR NOT, THIS IS A TEAM SPORT.
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME TEAM
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL WORKING FOR
OUR MUTUAL CONSTITUENTS IN OUR
DISTRICTS AND THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND OF COURSE, OUR
STAFF. WHAT WHAT WHAT CAN I SAY?
YOU HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY
STAFF. I AM SO INCREDIBLY PROUD.
AND I TRY TO TELL THEM ALL THE
TIME. WE HAVE QUARTERLY MEETINGS
EVERY SIX MONTHS, AND I TRY TO
LET THEM KNOW, BUT I DON'T THINK
WE EVER REALLY DO ENOUGH TO LET
OUR STAFF KNOW ABOUT HOW AWESOME
THEY REALLY ARE. THEY COME TO
WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY, NOT ONLY
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
DISTRICT, TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MANY HAVE BEEN WITH
ME MY ENTIRE CAREER. AS YOU
HEARD, THE PRO TEM SAY, EZRA,
SIOBHAN, LESLIE, SPAWN, MARISOL
PRIETO, VALLE I CAN FINALLY
PRONOUNCE YOUR NAME. MARISOL,
TOM BARTY, LOGAN PITTS AND RON
TURNER HAVE BEEN WITH ME FOR ALL
TEN YEARS. JUST INCREDIBLE TEAM.
MY GEO TEAM. YOU KNOW, THIS IS
AS WE KNOW IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE A
CHAIRMAN OR A CHAIRWOMAN IN THIS
HOUSE, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU GET A
LOT OF BILLS, YOU THERE ARE JUST
A LOT OF DIFFERENT FACTORS. AND
I'VE HAD A TEAM THAT HAS STOOD
TALL DURING THE ENTIRE TEAM
DURING THE ENTIRE, YOU KNOW,
SEVEN YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND THEY'VE
STREAMLINED IT FOR ME. AND I
JUST APPRECIATE THEM MORE THAN I
KNOW THEY KNOW. AND THANKS TO MY
DISTRICT STAFF FOR TIRELESSLY
DOING THE WORK, MANY OF US
FORGET ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
CONSTITUENT CASEWORK IS. WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT CONSTITUENT
CASEWORK MUCH UP HERE IN THE
CAPITOL BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING
THE HEAVY LIFTING, LIFTING AND
CONSTITUENT CASEWORK BACK HOME.
AND I HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY
AMAZED AT THE WORK THAT THEY DO
SOLVING PROBLEMS FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN OUR CONSTITUENTS
LIFE. AND SOMETIMES IT TOTALLY
AMAZES ME. I THINK, OH MY GOD,
HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET THIS
DONE IN ANY QUICK TIME FRAME?
BUT YOU KNOW, THEY DO IT BECAUSE
THEY'RE SMART. THEY COME TO WORK
WITH THAT IN MIND THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. I
DIDN'T START IN THE LEGISLATURE
THINKING THAT I WAS GOING TO BE
A LEADER IN WILDFIRE ISSUES, BUT
IT STARTED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
AS A PRO TEM SAID IN 2015, WITH
THE WILDFIRES IN LAKE COUNTY,
2017 THAT BURNED, YOU KNOW, MY
ENTIRE MY ENTIRE DISTRICT, IT
HITTING IT VERY, VERY HARD. BUT
I'VE ALSO TRIED TO TACKLE OTHER
ISSUES THAT NEED ATTENTION FROM
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
TO WATER RESOURCES AND SENIOR
ISSUES. AND I THINK IT WAS
MENTIONED ABOUT THE COCKTAILS TO
GO, YOU KNOW WHAT? WE GOT MORE
PUBLICITY OUT OF THAT BILL THAN
PROBABLY WE DESERVE. BUT DURING
COVID, THAT WAS A REALLY
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS. LET ME
SEE, SIR. BUT WHAT UNITES US
HERE IN THIS GREAT SENATE IS
GREATER THAN WHAT DIVIDES US. I
TRULY BELIEVE IN OUR ABILITY TO
MEET THE MOMENT AND OVERCOME OUR
CHALLENGES. SO MY ADVICE TO THE
INCOMING CLASS OF LEGISLATORS IS
TO TALK AND WORK TOGETHER AND TO
REMEMBER. AND WE CAN ALL
REMEMBER THIS. HOPEFULLY THAT
RARELY IS THERE AN ISSUE THAT IS
TRULY BLACK AND WHITE. WE NEED
TO RECOGNIZE OUR PROBLEMS, BUT
WE CAN'T FORGET THAT THE GOLDEN
STATE IS STILL THE GREATEST
PLACE TO LIVE AND WORK AND RAISE
A FAMILY, AND I FEEL BLESSED TO
HAVE BEEN HERE MY ENTIRE LIFE,
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE HERE
THE REST OF MY LIFE. YOU ALL
HAVE MADE A DIFFERENCE IN MY
CAREER. I CONSIDER YOU ALL
FRIENDS. I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AT THIS POINT IN
TIME TO REMEMBER MY FAMILY, THAT
YOU HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
ON THIS FLOOR BACK IN JUNE AND
WHEN WE WERE ON FAMILY VACATION
THIS SUMMER, THEY SAID, PAPA, I
COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT ALL THESE
SENATORS WERE THERE, SMILING
FROM EAR TO EAR, AND THEY WERE
JUST SO HAPPY. IT SEEMED LIKE,
TO SEE US. AND SO YOU MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR LIVES. AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY WIFE MARY,
AND MY FIVE KIDS AND THE 13
GRANDKIDS, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS NOT JUST ME. YOU'VE ALL
MET MISSED PIVOTAL MOMENTS IN
YOUR FAMILIES, IN YOUR EXTENDED
FAMILIES, BECAUSE YOU HAD
BUSINESS TO DO UP HERE. AND I
RESPECT ALL OF YOU FOR THAT.
WE'VE ALL DONE IT. BUT I WANT TO
THANK MY FAMILY FOR JUST HANGING
IN THERE WITH ME FOR JUST A MERE
25 YEARS OF THIS. BUT ALTHOUGH I
WILL BE RETIRING FROM ELECTED
POLITICS, I'M NOT GOING AWAY. I
THINK THERE'S ANOTHER CHAPTER
SOMEWHERE, SOMEHOW. BUT BY AND
LARGE IT WILL BE, YOU KNOW,
MAKING THE COMMUNITIES THAT I
LIVE IN AND SERVE, YOU KNOW,
BETTER FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MY DISTRICT.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU AND THE
EXTENDED SENATE STAFF EVERYWHERE
THROUGHOUT THIS GREAT BODY.
THANK YOU ALL VERY, VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE, SENATOR DODD.
AND LET'S SAY THANK YOU TO ALL
11 OUTGOING MEMBERS. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S MUCH
APPRECIATED. MEMBERS, WE WILL
NOW BREAK FOR 30 MINUTES FOR
LUNCH. WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
STAY IN THE BUILDING. WE HAVE
OVER 70 BILLS THAT WE WANT TO
GET DONE AFTER LUNCH, SO WE NEED
TO START BACK ON TIME. SO THANK
YOU. AND WE'RE GOING TO ASK ALL
THE RETIRING OUTGOING MEMBERS TO
COME FORWARD FOR A GROUP PHOTO.
ONCE AGAIN, WE WANT ALL OF OUR
OUTGOING MEMBERS RIGHT NOW
BEFORE YOU LEAVE THE FLOOR.
SENATOR ATKINS FOR A GROUP
PHOTO. SENATOR ROTH. CRYING
BRIAN DALY.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE READY
TO GET BACK ROCKING AND ROLLING.
WE'RE ON. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THERE
ARE FLOOR AMENDMENTS AT THE
DESK. THEY WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED. THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON RULES
SB 691.
SENATOR CORTEZ, FOR WHAT PURPOSE?
THE MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. MR.
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO PULL AB
871 FROM THE INACTIVE FILE SO
THAT IT CAN BE AMENDED. THE DESK
WILL NOTE. ANYTHING ELSE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SEEING
NO MICROPHONES. WE'RE NOW MOVING
ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING FILE ITEMS
ONE THROUGH 43. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL 863 WITH
AMENDMENTS 2427, WITH AMENDMENTS
2514, WITH AMENDMENTS 2091, WITH
AMENDMENTS 2465. WITH AMENDMENTS
23, 43, 25, 33, 31, 84, 28, 75,
1168, 13, 24, 21, 98, 23, 18,
31, 77, 32, 81, 30, 13, SECOND
READING WILL BE DEEMED READ. NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. ITEM 82. WE'RE STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM 82. SENATOR
ATKINS, SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2546 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RENDON. AN ACT RELATING
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
SENATOR ATKINS, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, AB 2546 BROADENS THE
DEFINITION OF MILITARY WEAPON
FOR THE PURPOSES OF STATE LAW
THAT REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ENGAGE IN A PUBLIC APPROVAL
PROCESS BEFORE ACQUIRING SUCH
WEAPONS. THE CURRENT DEFINITION
OF MILITARY WEAPONS USES BRAND
NAMES FOR SOME OF THESE WEAPONS,
INCLUDING ACOUSTIC WEAPONS. THIS
BILL INSTEAD USES GENERIC TERMS
FOR THOSE WEAPONS, THUS ENSURING
ALL MILITARY WEAPONS ARE SUBJECT
TO THE SAME GOOD PUBLIC PROCESS
DURING THE ACQUISITION. THIS WAS
LOOKED OVERLOOKED BEFORE AND
CREATED A LOOPHOLE AND A
PROBLEM. THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO
CORRECT THAT ASK FOR YOUR I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE AYE.
BECKER. BLAKESBURG AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE
DALLY. NÓ. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO
JONES. LAIRD. AYE LIMON. AYE.
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA
BOGUE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO
NO. SKINNER SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. I'M BURT. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL NO.
BECKER. AYE DODD. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. NGUYEN MILO.
EBCLC ROTH. AYE SKINNER. AYE
UMBERG. Ã. AYE WILK. AYE. AYE
IS 32 NO'S FOR THE MEASURE IS
ADOPTED. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ITEM 85 BY SENATOR DODD.
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1778 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNELLY AND ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR DODD, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNELLY TO PRESENT AB 1778.
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE MARIN
COUNTY AND ITS CITIES TO
ESTABLISH A VOLUNTARY PILOT
PROGRAM PROHIBITING INDIVIDUALS
UNDER THE AGE OF 16 FROM
OPERATING CLASS TWO ELECTRIC
BICYCLES. OUR PRIORITY IS TO
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN
ENCOURAGING THE USE OF
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION AND
ENSURING THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS, PARTICULARLY
OUR YOUNG RIDERS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
ITEM 85. A RODA-GIL A ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER I
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY DODD
I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE HURTADO I JONES
I LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN I
MILO I OCHOA PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
I SKINNER I SMILED CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WEINER
I WILK I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DALLEY I GROVE. MCGUIRE
GROVE I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I
OCHOA. BOGH. ICE 38. NÓ ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW.
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 86 BY SENATOR CORTEZ. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1904 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD AND ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR CORTEZ. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. PRESIDENT.
SENATORS AB 1904 WOULD GRANT
TRANSIT AGENCIES WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO EQUIP TRANSIT
BUSSES WITH A FLASHING LED YIELD
RIGHT OF WAY SIGN ON THE LEFT
REAR OF THE BUS PROVIDED THE
TRANSIT AGENCY'S GOVERNING BOARD
APPROVES A RESOLUTION TO ADOPT
SUCH SIGNAGE. THIS AUTHORITY
WOULD REDUCE TRAFFIC DELAYS
EXPERIENCED BY TRANSIT BUSSES
WHEN ATTEMPTING TO REENTER
TRAFFIC AND FACILITATE SAFER
REENTRY, ALLOWING OPERATORS TO
PROVIDE MORE TIMELY SERVICES.
THE BILL HAS NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING. SEEING. NONE,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FOLLOWING ITEM 86, ALLEN AVE,
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA I ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKESBERG I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLY NÓ DODD I D'ORAZIO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE NØ OTERO I JONES I LAIRD I
LIMON I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN NO NILO NO COBO
I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO NO SKINNER I SMILED
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG, I
WAHAB, I WIENER, I WILK NO, I
NO. JONES I TO NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO
GILL. NO MCGUIRE. AYES. 31 NOS.
EIGHT. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW.
MEMBERS, WE MOVE ON TO ITEM 87.
SENATOR ALLEN, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 761 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL FINANCE. SENATOR ALLEN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS. LA METRO IS IN THE
MIDDLE OF ONE OF THE LARGEST
REGIONAL TRANSIT EXPANSION
PROGRAMS IN THE NATION WITH THE
K LINE PROJECT THAT WILL CONNECT
FOUR MAJOR RAIL LINES AND SIX OF
THE HIGHEST RIDERSHIP BUS LINES
IN L.A. COUNTY. METRO AND LOS
ANGELES AREA CITIES ARE
EXPLORING THE UTILIZATION OF
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS TO SUPPORT
THE PROJECT. UNDER CURRENT LAW,
IFT MAY COLLECT TAX INCREMENT
ONLY FOR UP TO 45 YEARS FROM THE
DATE OF THE FIRST BOND ISSUANCE,
BUT BECAUSE OF THE RELATIVELY
SLOW APPRECIATION IN PROPERTY
VALUES, IN MANY CASES IT MAY
TAKE 10 TO 15 YEARS BEFORE
REVENUES ARE SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH
TO BORROW AGAINST OR BEGIN
PAYING DOWN DEBT. THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
JOBS ACT ALSO EXTENDED THE
LENGTH OF THE FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE,
FINANCE AND INNOVATION ACT. THE
TIFIA LOANS TO 75 YEARS, SO THIS
BILL WILL EXTEND THE IFDS TO 75
YEARS TO ALIGN WITH THE FEDERAL
TIFIA LOANS, ALLOWING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THE FLEXIBLE TERMS
OF A FEDERAL LOAN AND FUND MUCH
NEEDED TRANSIT PROJECTS THAT
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR OUR GOALS.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 87. ALLEN I, GILL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I D'ORAZIO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN I MELO I OCHOA I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SEYARTO I SKINNER I
SMILED CUEVAS I STERN I UMBER I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS HURTADO
MCGUIRE.
ALL RIGHT. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HURTADO I
MCGUIRE. AYES. 39. NOES. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW. MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM 88.
SENATOR BECKER, ARE YOU
PREPARED? HE IS SECRETARY. YOU
MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2967 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING. SENATOR
BECKER, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE. IN 2016, THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE TEACHER HOUSING ACT
TO FACILITATE THE CREATION OF
HOUSING THAT IS SPECIFICALLY SET
ASIDE FOR TEACHER AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES. THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE TEACHER HOUSING ACT
TO INCLUDE EMPLOYEES OF PUBLICLY
FUNDED NONPROFITS THAT OPERATE
ON SCHOOL DISTRICT PROPERTY AND
SERVE CHILDREN FROM LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã RODA-GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DAWLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE POTATO.
AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE
MEN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
MILO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY
GROVE. MCGUIRE NGUYEN. MILO AYE.
SEYARTO WHEN? AYE. AGE 36. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM
92. SENATOR LAIRD. HE HAS
PREPARED. SECRETARY MAY READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2399 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIORDAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO MOBILE HOMES. SENATOR LAIRD,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 2399 REVISES AN
ANNUAL NOTICE TO HELP MOBILE
HOME TENANTS BE AWARE OF LEGAL
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO THEM UNDER
THE MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LAW
PROTECTION PROGRAM. THE MORRELL
ÁP. THIS BILL INCREASES TENANTS
AWARENESS OF THEIR RIGHTS AND
INFORMS THEM OF HOW THOSE RIGHTS
MIGHT BE PROTECTED. THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN Ã I'LL RODA-GIL NO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLASER.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. NO. LAIRD
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NO.
MILO NO. OKOBOJI. NO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER I
SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GLAZER AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE WILK. NO AYE.
STURDY NO'S NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW. MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
ITEM 93. SENATOR WIENER. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2359 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
AYE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, RIGHT IN
TIME FOR THE SAU, I AM
PRESENTING AB 2359 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING, THIS
DISTRICT BILL STRENGTHENS SAN
FRANCISCO'S SUCCESSFUL
NEIGHBORHOOD LIQUOR LICENSE
PROGRAM. THE LEGISLATURE CREATED
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD LIQUOR LICENSE
PROGRAM, KNOWN AS THE TYPE 87
LICENSE, TO HELP SPUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
OUTER NEIGHBORHOODS. THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS TEND TO HAVE LESS
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND NIGHTLIFE
THAN OTHER PARTS OF THE CITY,
WHICH MAKES IT HARDER FOR THEM
TO COMPETE FOR NORMAL LIQUOR
LICENSES, WHICH CAN BE QUITE
EXPENSIVE. CURRENTLY, THE
PROGRAM ALLOWS FOR 30 AFFORDABLE
AND NONTRANSFERABLE LIQUOR
LICENSES IN SPECIFIC
NEIGHBORHOODS, AND THIS BILL
WILL INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
THOSE LICENSES FROM 30 TO 40 AND
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING
NONE MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 39. NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. AND
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ITEM 97. SENATOR UMBERG, HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2215 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES, I'LL TRY TO KEEP
MY VOICE UP THIS BILL EMPOWERS
THE COP ON THE BEAT, EMPOWERS AN
ARRESTING OFFICER TO MAKE A
DECISION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEONE WHO IS, FOR EXAMPLE,
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS OR
ITS SEVERE POVERTY, RATHER THAN
TAKING THAT PERSON TO JAIL, MAY
TAKE THAT PERSON TO A DIVERSION
PROGRAM, WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT BILLS THAT DEAL WITH
DIVERSION. ULTIMATELY DIVERSION
EARLY ON IS A COST SAVING PUBLIC
SAFETY MEASURE. I URGE AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ALL RIGHT,
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ALVARADO GILL ARCHULETA,
I ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER, I
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NÓ
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLASER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE NØ HURTADO I
JONES NO. LAIRD I LEMON I
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN NO NILO. NO OCHOA.
BOGUE NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NO. SKINNER
I CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG I
WAHAB, I WIENER, I WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GILL. NO MCGUIRE. AYES
30. NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 100.
SENATOR WILK IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1853 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BILL PADUA. AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION. SENATOR WILK,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 1853, WHICH
PROPOSES TO UPDATE THE SAN
JOAQUIN REGIONAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT AUTHORITIES. THIS BILL
WILL ADVANCE TWO CHANGES. FIRST,
IT WILL BRING MORE EQUITABLE PAY
SKILL TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICT. SAN
JOAQUIN RTD CURRENTLY RANKS
AMONG THE BOTTOM THREE DISTRICTS
FOR COMPENSATION. SECOND, THE
BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE RTD TO
INVEST OR DEPOSIT FUNDS AT A
CITY, COUNTY, OR LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCY MAY PLACE IN ITS RESERVES
WHILE INCLUDING THE APPROPRIATE
LIMITS THAT APPLY TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE, THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS MEASURE?
AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 103.
SENATOR UMBERG, HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2505 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL. AN ACT RELATING TO
ATTORNEYS. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. AB 2505 BY MEMBER
GABRIEL SIMPLY UNDERLINES THE
REQUIREMENT, OR AT LEAST THE
MORAL OBLIGATION. IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE LEGAL PROFESSION,
TO PROVIDE SOME SORT OF PRO BONO
SERVICE, THAT'S PART OF BEING A
PROFESSIONAL. THIS BILL SIMPLY
SAYS THAT WHEN YOU PERFORM PRO
BONO SERVICES, YOU CAN REPORT
THAT TO THE STATE BAR. YOU'RE
NOT REQUIRED TO PERFORM PRO BONO
SERVICES, ALTHOUGH IT IS
RECOMMENDED IT SIMPLY PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY AND EMPOWERS
ATTORNEYS TO REPORT TO THE STATE
BAR WHAT THEY'VE COMPLETED OR
THEIR FIRM HAS COMPLETED IN
TERMS OF PRO BONO SERVICES, I
URGE AND I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
HEARING. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 103. ALLEN AYE. GILL NØ
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMON.
AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO JOBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER A
SMALL WILK. RIVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. AYE. WAHAB AYE
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NÓ AYES
30. NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ITEM 104. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, ARE YOU PREPARED? HE
IS SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1855 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA AN ACT RELATING
TO OPEN MEETINGS. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AB 1855 WILL MODERNIZE
THE BROWN ACT. THIS IS A BARRIER
FOR MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE
DISABLED, HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION, OR OTHERWISE
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
MEETINGS IN PERSON. AB 1855
PROTECTS PUBLIC ACCESS AND
ALLOWS ELIGIBLE LEGISLATIVE
BODIES OF A STUDENT ORGANIZATION
TO USE ALTERNATE
TELECONFERENCING PROVISIONS. IF
APPROVED BY THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND ADOPTED BY AN
ELIGIBLE BODY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING. SEEING. NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 104. ALLEN. I SAID AYE,
GILL. NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALI. NÓ.
DODD. AYE. HUESO. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO. AYE JONES.
LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. NO MILO. NO. OJOBO
NO. PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE.
SEYARTO NO. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG I
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CABALLERO JONES.
MCGUIRE. AYE. 29 NOES EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
107. SENATOR ATKINS, ARE YOU
PREPARED? NO. I'M SORRY, I
MISSED 106. WE'RE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM 106, SENATOR PADILLA. HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2485 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MANCINI. AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 2435. SINCE 2012, CALIFORNIA
COVERED CALIFORNIA HAS ENGAGED
IN A VERY PUBLIC PROCESS WITH
ROBUST STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
WHEN PROPOSING AND ADOPTING
REGULATORY CHANGES. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GRANTED COVERED
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY RULEMAKING
AUTHORITY BECAUSE IT MUST ACT
FASTER THAN THE TRADITIONAL
RULEMAKING FRAMEWORK TO PROCESS
AND IMPLEMENT CHANGES IN LAW
THAT AFFECT HEALTH CARE ACCESS
FOR CONSUMERS. THIS EMERGENCY
AUTHORITY EXPIRES JANUARY 1ST,
2025. CONSUMERS WILL BE AT RISK
OF SIGNIFICANT DELAY IN NEW
BENEFITS OR PROTECTIONS IF
COVERED. CALIFORNIA IS NOT ABLE
TO QUICKLY CONFORM TO NEW STATE
AND FEDERAL POLICY. AB 2435
WOULD EXTEND THE AUTHORITY FOR
EMERGENCY RULEMAKING UNTIL
JANUARY 1ST, 2030. IN ORDER TO
ADEQUATELY AND PROMPTLY REACT TO
BOTH ANNUAL AND ONGOING FEDERAL
AND STATE RULES. ONCE THE
RULEMAKING PROCESS HAS BEEN
COMPLETED, COVERED, CALIFORNIA
MUST THEN COMPLETE A PERMANENT
RULEMAKING PROCESS WITHIN FIVE
YEARS. THIS IS TO ALLOW YET
ANOTHER ROUND OF PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT THROUGH COMMENTS AT
BOARD MEETINGS AND REGULAR
RULEMAKING PROCESSES, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALI
NO. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMON
AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO COBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE JONES.
MCGUIRE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ONE MORE TIME. GROVE.
NO JONES. MCGUIRE. AYE. 31. NO.
SEVEN. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM 107.
SENATOR ATKINS. SHE'S READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2442 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZIMMER. AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALING ARTS. SENATOR ATKINS,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWO 442 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD. IN RECENT
YEARS, THE NUMBER OF STATES WITH
LAWS OR POLICIES RESTRICTING
ACCESS TO GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
HAS DRAMATICALLY INCREASED FROM
JUST FOUR STATES IN JUNE OF 2022
TO 23 STATES IN 2024. GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE IS HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED, AND DELAYING IT
WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO PATIENTS
SEEKING CARE. AB 2442 SEEKS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO THIS CARE IN
ANTICIPATION OF A SURGE IN
OUT-OF-STATE PATIENTS SEEKING
CARE IN CALIFORNIA. THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES THE
EXPEDITED PROCESSING OF
LICENSURE APPLICATIONS FOR
PROVIDERS, DEMONSTRATING A
COMMITMENT TO GENDER AFFIRMING
HEALTH CARE OR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WITHIN THEIR
LICENSED SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG SERVED AS A
SAFE HAVEN FOR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE AND GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE. AB 2442 REFLECTS OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO UPHOLDING
THESE VALUES AND ENSURING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HEARING.
SEEING NONE, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE AT 107. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBURG AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. NÓ. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO COBO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL MCGUIRE. BORG
AYE. STURDY NO. SEVEN. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM 118.
SENATOR LAIRD, HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2493 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN. AN ACT RELATING
TO TENANCY. SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2493 WILL PREVENT A
LANDLORD OR PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
COMPANY FROM CHARGING A
POTENTIAL APPLICANT A FEE TO BE
ENTERED ONTO A WAITING LIST FOR
A RENTAL UNIT. IF NO RENTAL UNIT
IS AVAILABLE AT THE TIME, OR
WILL NOT BE AVAILABLE IN A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME, A
COMMON CONSTITUENT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, PELLERIN AND I WAS
CHARGED $2,000 TO BE ON VARIOUS
WAITING LISTS WHEN UNITS WEREN'T
AVAILABLE, AND BY THE TIME SHE
SCORED A RENTAL UNIT, SHE'D
SPENT HER SAVINGS SET ASIDE FOR
SECURITY DEPOSIT AND HAD TO
BORROW MONEY FROM HER FRIENDS
AND FAMILY. AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY THAT
REMOVED THE OPPOSITION OF THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
AND SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 118. ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO.
GILL ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER BLAKESBERG.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. MILO. NO. COBO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO.
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK NO!
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO GILL. NO. ARCHULETA
BECKER. AYE BLAKE. SPEAR
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN NO. BOAT AYE. 28
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. I
MEAN, I'M SORRY. AYES 28 NOES
EIGHT. THE MEASURE PASSES. MY
BAD. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
120, SENATOR NGUYEN. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2081 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIS. AN ACT RELATING TO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT.
SENATOR NGUYEN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 2081 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LAURIE DAVIES. AB 2081
REQUIRES OPERATORS OF SUBSTANCE
USE TREATMENT FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE ON THEIR WEBSITE AND ON
ANY INTAKE PAPERWORK, A
DISCLOSURE THAT LINKS TO THE DCS
RUN LIST OF FACILITIES WHOSE
LICENSURE IS EITHER ON
PROBATION, HAS BEEN SUSPENDED,
OR HAS BEEN REVOKED. THIS CAN BE
GREATLY BENEFICIAL TO PATIENTS
BY EMPOWERING THEM TO LOOK
DEEPER INTO WHICH GOVERNMENT
AGENCY OVERSEES THESE
FACILITIES, THEY CAN LEARN MORE
ABOUT TREATMENT OPTIONS AND
PROTECTIONS GUARANTEED TO THEM.
AS A PATIENT. IT ALSO EMPOWERS
DCS TO ACT TO ASSESS A PENALTY
THAT IS IN LINE WITH THEIR
CURRENT PENALTY STRUCTURE ON ANY
FACILITY THAT DOESN'T FULFILL
THE NEW REQUIREMENTS. AB 2081
HAS YET TO RECEIVE A NO NO, NO
VOTE ON ITS WAY TO US HERE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR. THIS BILL IS
ALSO SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND HAS RECEIVED SUPPORT
FROM CITIES ACROSS THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM 123.
SENATOR PADILLA. HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2876 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO PUPIL INSTRUCTION. SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2876 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, WHICH WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL K THROUGH 12 STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE PREPARED WITH
THE I LITERACY SKILLS NECESSARY
TO COMPREHEND BASIC AI
PRINCIPLES AND APPLICATIONS.
THIS ESSENTIAL CURRICULUM WILL
BUILD STUDENTS UNDERSTANDING OF
THE IMPLICATIONS, LIMITATIONS,
AND ETHICAL CONSIDERATIONS OF
AI. THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTS THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION TO CONSIDER
INCORPORATING AI LITERACY
CONTENT INTO RELEVANT CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS. WHEN THOSE
FRAMEWORKS ARE NEXT REVISED AS
AI GROWS IN POPULARITY. CHILDREN
GROWING UP IN TODAY'S DIGITAL
WORLD NEED TO BE BETTER EQUIPPED
THAN ANY GENERATION BEFORE THEM.
TO UNDERSTAND THESE PRINCIPLES.
THIS BILL HAS HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON PHÐ. ITEM 123.
ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAESER GONZALEZ. GLAESER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. AYE. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLEY AYE. DURAZO. AYE MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN. AYE AYES 39. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 140.
SENATOR STERN, HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 796 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
ATHLETIC TRAINERS. SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS. THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH CERTIFICATION AND
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR
ATHLETIC TRAINERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND PROHIBIT INDIVIDUALS FROM
CALLING THEMSELVES ATHLETIC
TRAINERS UNLESS THEY MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION RECOGNIZES
THAT ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE
ALLIED HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
AND CLASSIFIED BY SUCH AS U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. EVERY OTHER STATE
REGULATES THIS CERTIFICATION
EXCEPT CALIFORNIA. SO THIS MEANS
THAT UNTRAINED INDIVIDUALS ARE
CALLING THEMSELVES ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AND WORKING AS SUCH.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT REMEDYING
THIS GAP AND IMPROVING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR YOUTH.
SPORTS PLAYERS, ALL THE WAY UP
TO PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES. NÓ NO
VOTES IN POLICY COMMITTEE. NO
OPPOSITION. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING ON TO FINAL ITEM.
142. SENATOR NIELLO. Þ NO. I'M
SORRY. I HAVE SENATOR MIN FIRST.
MY BAD. I'M LIKE SECRETARY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1827 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PAPAN. AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCE. SENATOR MIN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THEY
CALL ME THE KOREAN VERSION OF
SENATOR NILO. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPAN, I PRESENT
AB 1827, WHICH SIMPLY REAFFIRMS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S WATER
SUPPLIERS CAN CONTINUE TO
INCLUDE THE INCREMENTALLY HIGHER
COSTS OF WATER SERVICE DUE TO
HIGHER WATER USE WITHIN THE
WATER RATES CHARGED TO CUSTOMERS
WHO DRIVE THOSE COSTS WITHIN A
PARTICULAR TIER OR TYPE. IT ALSO
REAFFIRMS THAT THOSE COSTS CAN
BE REALLOCATED AMONG THOSE
HIGHER USE CUSTOMERS, USING ANY
METHOD THAT REASONABLY ASSESSES
THE COSTS OF SERVING THOSE
PARCELS, INCLUDING USING METER
SIZE AND PEAKING FACTORS. WATER
CUSTOMERS WHO USE MORE WATER
THAN OTHER SIMILARLY SITUATED
CUSTOMERS INCREASE WATER
SUPPLIERS OVERALL COST OF
PROVIDING WATER SERVICE. DUE TO
THE HIGHER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
BUILDING, OPERATING AND
MAINTAINING A LARGER WATER
SYSTEM THAT CAN MEET THOSE
DEMANDS. NOW, PROPOSITION 218
ALLOWS WATER SUPPLIERS TO RECOUP
THE LEGITIMATE COSTS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THAT HIGHER
WATER USE FROM THOSE HIGHER
WATER USING CUSTOMERS, BUT
RECENT LITIGATION HAS SOUGHT TO
CALL THIS INTO QUESTION, WHICH
RISKS REQUIRING WATER SUPPLIERS
TO SPREAD THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH SERVING HIGHER WATER USE.
CUSTOMERS ACROSS THEIR ENTIRE
CUSTOMER BASE, EFFECTIVELY
FORCING POTENTIALLY FORCING
LOWER WATER USE CALIFORNIANS TO
PAY MORE FOR WATER. AB 1828, TO
BE CLEAR, WOULD NOT PERMIT A
WATER SUPPLIER TO VIOLATE
PROPOSITION 218 AND SET WATER
RATES ABOVE THE COST OF SERVICE
OR SUBSIDIZE LOWER WATER USERS.
WATER BILLS WITH CHARGES PLACED
ON HIGHER USE CUSTOMERS. IT
SIMPLY PRESERVES PROP 218
PROPORTIONALITY AND COST OF
SERVICE PRINCIPLES, ALLOWING
WATER SUPPLIERS TO CONTINUE
USING THE REASONABLE METHODS
THEY HAVE USED FOR DECADES TO
ALLOCATE COSTS. AB 1828 SEEKS TO
PROTECT CURRENT RATE SETTING
PRACTICES, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MATTER? HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO,
GIL ARCHULETA, I ASHBY, I.
ATKINS, I. BECKER I. BLAKE.
SPEER I. BRADFORD. I. CABALLERO
I. CORTEZ I. DALLY NÓ. DODD I.
DURAZO I MEAN I. GLAESER I.
GONZALEZ. I. GROVE NØ. HURTADO
JONES. LAIRD I. LIMON I. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR I. MIN. I. NEWMAN, I.
NGUYEN. NÓ. NILO I. NØ JOBO.
PADILLA I. PORTANTINO I. ROTH I.
RUBIO I. SEYARTO. NÓ SKINNER. I
SMILED. CUEVAS I. STERN, I.
UMBERG, I. I. WAHAB I. WIENER I.
WILK. NÓ PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GILL. NO
HURTADO. JONES MCGUIRE. OCHOA
BOGUE. NO. AYES 29. ALL RIGHT.
JONES YEAH. ALL RIGHT. I. AYES
20. WE CLOSED IT, OR ARE WE
GOING TO LEAVE IT OVER? YES.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, I'M
FOLLOWING A 142. EYES ARE 29.
THE NOES ARE NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW. MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 143. SENATOR LAIRD. NO. I'M
SORRY, I'M SORRY. I'M SENATOR
NILO. NOW, I'VE MESSED THAT UP
TWICE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
THANK Þ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2457 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. AN ACT
RELATING TO MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT ACT. SENATOR NILO, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND FOR WAKING ME UP
UNEXPECTEDLY JUST PRIOR TO THE
LAST ITEM. I AM PRESENTING AB
2457 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
MCCARTY. AB 2457 IS A DISTRICT
BILL SPONSORED BY THE SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT,
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN HERE AS
SMUD. THIS BILL EXTENDS THE
SUNSET CURRENTLY IN STATUTE SET
BY A PREVIOUS BILL OF
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY'S AB 689. IN
2019, WHICH ALLOWS SMUD TO ENTER
INTO PARTNERSHIPS THAT RESULT IN
FINANCIAL RETURNS, WHICH IT HAS
SUCCESSFULLY UTILIZED TO HELP
KEEP SMUD RATES LOW. THOSE OF US
THAT LIVE IN THIS REGION KNOW
THAT THEY ARE AMONG THE LOWEST
AND GIVES SMUD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INVEST IN CLEAN ENERGY,
HELPING THEM REACH THEIR VERY
AMBITIOUS CARBON EMISSION GOALS.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU WILL EXTEND
THE SUNSET TEN YEARS AND CAPS
THEIR SMUD AT SIX PARTNERSHIPS
TOTAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? WE'RE GOING
TO CALL THE ROLL NOW. OKAY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. ITEM 143. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE.
DODD. AYE. RAZO I. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE I. HURTADO AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I MEAN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. AYE.
NILO. AYE. BOGUE. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. BROD. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER
I SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. JONES. MCGUIRE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. JONES AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 144. SENATOR
LAIRD. HE HAS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2682 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. AN ACT RELATING TO
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACE AUTHORITY. SENATOR LARRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA,
WHICH WOULD AMEND THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY ENABLING ACT TO
IMPROVE ITS FUNCTIONS AND ALIGN
THEM WITH SIMILAR JURISDICTIONS.
IT WOULD ALLOW THE AUTHORITY TO
PURCHASE LANDS IN FEE TITLE FROM
WILLING SELLERS, ALLOWED THE
AUTHORITY TO AUTHORIZE THE
GENERAL MANAGER TO BIND THE
DISTRICT TO CERTAIN CONTRACTS,
INCREASE THE CONTRACTING
THRESHOLDS FOR MATERIALS AND
EQUIPMENT WHICH HAVE NOT BEEN
INCREASED SINCE 2012, ENABLE THE
AUTHORITY TO FINANCE FACILITIES
AND ISSUE BONDS PURSUANT TO THE
MELLO-ROOS ACT AND AMEND THE
UNIFORMITY CLAUSE TO ALLOW THEM
TO CHARGE LOWER TAX RATES TO
SENIORS, WHICH OTHER DISTRICTS
HAVE. THIS IS VERY DESIRED
FLEXIBILITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE, HEARING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ DALLEY.
NØ. DODD. AYE. RAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENJIVAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO.
OKOBO. NO. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL. NO CORTEZ. AYE
MCGUIRE. WILK AYES. 30. NOES
EIGHT. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM ONE FIVE FOR
SENATOR DURAZO. SHE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2224 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. AN ACT RELATING
TO SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILES.
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
JUVENILE STATUS, COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS SIJS, PROVIDES
LIMITED IMMIGRATION RELIEF FOR
VULNERABLE UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN
AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
ABUSED, NEGLECTED OR LEFT
WITHOUT ONE OR BOTH OF THEIR
PARENTS. UNFORTUNATELY SIJS
APPLICANTS FACE LENGTHY DELAYS
IN THEIR APPLICATION PROCESS.
THIS BILL AIMS TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG BY ENSURING CLARITY AND
EXPEDIENCY IN THE STATE'S ROLE
IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS. BY
CLARIFYING THAT THE COURT CAN
APPOINT A PARENT AS A GUARDIAN
FOR THEIR UNMARRIED CHILD IF
THEY ARE OVER THE AGE OF 18, BUT
UNDER 21, AND PURSUING SIJS AND
ENSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE THE SIJS COURT ORDER IN
A TIMELY MANNER. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? MEMBERS.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? SEEING NONE. AYES 38. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FINAL ITEM
158. SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SHE IS READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2749 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD. AN ACT
RELATING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND GOOD AFTERNOON,
COLLEAGUES. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD, I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2749. THIS
BILL WOULD REVISE AND CLARIFY
EXISTING LAW PROVISIONS THAT
GRANT WORKERS ON STRIKE ACCESS
TO EXPEDITED AND SUBSIDIZED
COVERAGE THROUGH CALIFORNIA CARE
COVERED CALIFORNIA. IN 2022, THE
STATE REQUIRED COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO ADMINISTER A
PROGRAM OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO HELP WORKERS WHO LOSE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE DUE TO A
LABOR DISPUTE. THROUGH AN
UNPRECEDENTED WAVE OF STRIKES,
WE FOUND THAT WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE WERE RECEIVING LESS HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. AB 2749 CLARIFIES
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM TO
REACH THE INTENDED TARGET OF
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THE STRIKE.
WE WANT TO FURTHER PROTECT
WORKERS AND ENSURE THEY OBTAIN
THEIR BENEFITS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING. NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBURG AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
OCHOA AYE. PERDUE AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DOLLY GROVE. JONES.
MCGUIRE NGUYEN. MILO RUBIO. AYE
SEYARTO. AYES 33. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW. MEMBERS.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 181.
SENATOR CABALLERO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2257 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON. AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR CABALLERO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2257 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON. THIS BILL WILL
ENHANCE THE TRANSPARENCY, THE
EFFICACY AND FAIRNESS OF THE
RATE SETTING PROCESS FOR WATER
AND SEWER SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. AT ITS CORE, THE
BILL IS ABOUT FOSTERING A
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOG BETWEEN
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND THE PEOPLE
THEY SERVE. UNDER EXISTING LAW,
PROPOSITION 218 REQUIRES PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE ADVANCE
NOTICE TO PROPERTY OWNERS IN
INCLUDING A PUBLIC HEARING FOR
PROTEST, AND RESTRICTS THE
IMPOSITION OF FEES UNLESS THEY
REPRESENT THE ACTUAL COST OF
SERVICES. OFTEN, LEGAL
CHALLENGES COME WITHOUT PRIOR
OBJECTIONS BEING RAISED DURING
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD,
LEADING TO COSTLY AND UNFORESEEN
LAWSUITS THAT STRAIN THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES OF THESE
AGENCIES. AB 2257 WILL CREATE A
TRANSPARENT AND COMMUNICATIVE
PROCEDURE TO ALLOW FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT TO BE SUBMITTED
REGARDING WATER AND SEWER RATE
ASSESSMENT FEES. THE AGENCIES
INVOLVED WILL THEN BE REQUIRED
TO RESPOND TO EACH COMMENT IN
WRITING, BEFORE ANY ACTION ON
RATES CAN BE TAKEN. THIS WILL
RESOLVE DISPUTES EARLY AND
REDUCE THE FREQUENCY OF
LITIGATION, WHICH CAN BE COSTLY
AND TIME CONSUMING FOR BOTH
PARTIES. BY PROMOTING EARLY AND
MEANINGFUL DIALOG BETWEEN PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND RATEPAYERS. THIS
BILL LAYS THE GROUNDWORK FOR A
MORE EQUITABLE, EQUITABLE,
RELIABLE, AND EFFECTIVE WATER
AND SEWER SERVICE RATES IN
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 181 OAN Ã
ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NØ DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO JONES.
LAIRD AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO. OKOBO
NÓ. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. NØ
SKINNER. I SMILED. CUEVAS STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE
GLAZER. NO HURTADO. NO. JONES
MCGUIRE. SMALLED CUEVAS. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ONE MORE TIME. ALVARADO. GILL NO.
JONES MCGUIRE. HIS LICCARDO. NO.
OR SO WE'RE GOOD. WE'RE GOOD.
OKAY. WE'RE GOOD. AYES 28. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. I'M
SORRY. GOLLY! AYES 28. NOES TEN.
AYES 28. NOES TEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW. MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 184.
SENATOR ASHBY. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2123 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
PAID FAMILY LEAVE. SENATOR ASHBY.
THE TWO. 123. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN PAPAN. AB 2123.
REMOVES AN UNNECESSARY HURDLE
FOR INDIVIDUALS ATTEMPTING TO
ACCESS THEIR PAID FAMILY LEAVE
BENEFITS. WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS
LED THE NATION IN IMPLEMENTING
PAID FAMILY, WORKERS STILL FACE
BARRIERS IN ACCESSING THE
BENEFIT THAT THEY CONTRIBUTE TO.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, EMPLOYERS CAN
REQUIRE AN EMPLOYEE TO USE UP
TWO WEEKS OF ACCRUED VACATION,
LEAVE PRIOR TO ACCESSING THEIR
FL BENEFITS. AB 2123 WILL SUNSET
THAT PROVISION AND ENSURE THAT
WORKERS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THEIR
FL BENEFITS WHEN THEY NEED THEM.
MOST URGENT I VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. AYES 3938. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. ALL
RIGHT. MOVING ON TO FALL. ITEM
185. SENATOR RUBIO. SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2129 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2129 THAT WILL
IMPROVE ACCESS TO LONG ACTING
REVERSIBLE CONTRACEPTION IN
HOSPITALS AND BIRTH CENTERS BY
STANDARDIZING BENEFITS ACROSS
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE INSURANCE
PLANS. IT WILL SUPPORT MOTHERS
WITH TIMELY ACCESS TO THEIR
CONTRACEPTIVE NEEDS WITHOUT THE
HASSLE OF COMPLEX INSURANCE
BENEFIT NAVIGATION BY BOTH
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS. THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION ON
FILE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING. NONE.
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM 185.
SEEING. NONE. AYES 38. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 188. SENATOR BREAKSPEARE.
SHE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1784 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS. SENATOR
BREAKSPEARE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS. SINCE
1913, CALIFORNIA LAW HAS
PROHIBITED A PERSON FROM RUNNING
FOR MORE THAN ONE OFFICE AT A
PRIMARY ELECTION. BUT IN
DECEMBER, A SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE ORDERED THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO PLACE A
CANDIDATE'S NAME ON THE BALLOT
FOR A CONGRESSIONAL SEAT, EVEN
THOUGH THAT SAME CANDIDATE WAS
ALREADY ON THE BALLOT FOR A SEAT
IN THE ASSEMBLY. AB 1784
CLARIFIES THAT STATE LAW
PROHIBITS A PERSON FROM FILING
NOMINATION DOCUMENTS FOR MORE
THAN ONE OFFICE AT A PRIMARY
ELECTION. THIS CLARIFICATION
ENSURES THAT THE LAW IS APPLIED
IN THE WAY THAT IT HAS BEEN
INTERPRETED FOR DECADES. AB 1784
HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS, THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA, AND SECRETARY OF
STATE WEBER, AMONG OTHERS. THERE
HAS THERE IS NO OPPOSITION, AND
THIS HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
MEMBERS. THIS TIÂU IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL HERE?
SEEING NONE. AYES 38. NOES ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO ITEM 193. SENATOR
CABALLERO. SHE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1921 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
ENERGY. SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB 1921 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN, WHICH
UPDATES AND CLARIFIES THE
DEFINITION OF A RENEWABLE
ELECTRICAL GENERATION FACILITY
TO INCLUDE LINEAR GENERATORS
USING RFPS. ELIGIBLE FUELS.
LINEAR GENERATORS ARE A CUTTING
EDGE TECHNOLOGY THAT OFFERS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
RENEWABLE POWER. AT THE FLIP OF
A SWITCH, THEY CAN RUN ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FUELS,
INCLUDING MANY THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR RPS. NOT UNLIKE FUEL CELLS
THAT ARE ALREADY INCLUDED IN THE
DEFINITION. IF LINEAR GENERATORS
REMAIN EXCLUDED FROM RPS, THE
STATE WILL HAVE AN INSUFFICIENT
PORTFOLIO OF ON DEMAND POWER. AS
WE APPROACH OUR 2045 DEADLINE.
AB 1921 WILL ESTABLISH
TECHNOLOGY PARITY AND HELP MEET
THE STATE'S RENEWABLE ENERGY
GOAL. THE BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON ITEM 193. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER VÌ.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DAWLEY AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. OR DATO. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. AYE.
OKOBO. AYE. PODIUM AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO SCOTT. I
SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES. MCGUIRE.
MIN AYE. NGUYEN SEYARTO. AYES
36. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
196. SENATOR BECKER. HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2021 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR
BECKER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2021. THIS BILL INCREASES THE
FINES ASSOCIATED WITH SELLING
TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO ANYONE UNDER
THE AGE OF SIX. OF 21. THESE
FINES HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED
SINCE 2016. AND OUR YOUTH
DESERVE BETTER PROTECTIONS TO
HOLD BAD ACTORS RESPONSIBLE FOR
POISONING OUR CHILDREN WITH
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. THIS HAS HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SEEING NO
MICROPHONE, SECRETARY, YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBURG. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY DODD. AYE.
DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NILO. AYE
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. I SAY NO,
SKINNER. I SMILED, CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EGGMAN! AYE. GROVE JONES.
MCGUIRE. MEN. AYE. NGUYEN EBCLC.
EYES 33 NOES ONE. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW. MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 200. SENATE-TV
PORTANTINO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2062 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO CREDIT UNIONS. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU, MR. PRO
TEM AND MEMBERS, I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2062, WHICH WILL
UPDATE AND STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIA'S CREDIT UNION
CHARTER. CREDIT UNIONS CAN
EITHER RECEIVE A STATE CHARTER
OR A FEDERAL CHARTER. MAKING
SURE CALIFORNIA'S STATE CHARTER
IS COMPETITIVE IS IMPORTANT. WE
WANT TO WE WANT CREDIT UNIONS TO
FORM HERE, AND WE WANT THEM TO
SUCCEED. THESE CHANGES ARE
MODEST, BUT THEY WILL HELP
CREDIT UNIONS BETTER SERVE THEIR
MEMBERSHIP. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
APPLYING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
SEEING NONE. AYES 38. NOES ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 205. SENATOR SKINNER.
SHE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2199 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS. AB
2199 PROVIDES A NARROW CEQA
EXEMPTION TO LIMITED INFILL
HOUSING PROJECTS WITHIN
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY AREAS.
NINE PROJECTS. THIS RATHER THAT,
IS ALREADY IN STATUTE. WHAT I
JUST DESCRIBED IN 2018, IT WAS
PASSED THIS NARROW EXEMPTION IN
THE UNINCORPORATED AREAS, BUT
SINCE THAT TIME IT HAS ONLY BEEN
USED WITH FOR NINE PROJECTS. THE
EXEMPTION ON THIS, BILL SUNSETS
NEXT YEAR. SO IT'S KIND OF A
PILOT. SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES
BEFORE YOU. 2199 IS EXTENDS THAT
PROVISION FOR AN ADDITIONAL
SEVEN YEARS IN ORDER TO PROMOTE
INFILL HOUSING PROJECTS WITHIN
THOSE UNINCORPORATED AREAS
WITHIN COUNTIES. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEEING
NONE. AYES 38. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM 206.
SENATOR GLAZIER. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2214 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER B¢O KHN. AN ACT
RELATING TO POLLUTION. SENATOR.
GLAZIER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL TO LEAD AN
INTERAGENCY COORDINATION GROUP
TO IDENTIFY AND RECOMMEND
NECESSARY STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OUTLINED IN THE STATEWIDE
MICROPLASTICS STRATEGY. MEMBERS
WERE FACED WITH AN URGENT THREAT
TO OUR ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
HEALTH, AND THAT'S
MICROPLASTICS. THESE PARTICLES
ARE FOUND IN OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT, FOOD AND EVEN OUR
OWN BODIES. THIS BILL IS A
PRUDENT STEP FORWARD AND
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY
MCCALL, CALL THE ROLL ON THIS
ITEM. ELLEN I. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN MILO. OCHOA.
BOGH PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. NØ. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALY MCGUIRE. NGUYEN.
GROVE. I DON'T KNOW. KELLY. NO.
DALY. NO NGUYEN. NILO. NO OKUBO.
NO. AGE 32. NOES SIX. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO ITEM 208, SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2238 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE. AN ACT RELATING TO
TAX ADMINISTRATION. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. AB
2238 ADDS THE STATE TREASURER
AND LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. CURRENTLY,
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS
THREE MEMBERS THE COMPTROLLER,
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE AND THE
CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION. THE STATE
TREASURER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
BANKING, CASH AND ASSET
MANAGEMENT, AND DEBT ISSUANCE.
GIVEN FISCAL ISSUES, THE
TREASURER SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
DECISIONS AFFECTING STATE
REVENUES. WE'VE COLLABORATED
WITH THE BOE TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS, AND THEY ARE NOW
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE. BOTH
THE STATE TREASURER AND
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR SUPPORT
SUPPORT JOINING THE BOARD. AB
2238 SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
DECISIONS MADE BY THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD ARE INFORMED BY A
THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR
IMPLICATIONS AND IMPACTS. BY
SECURING THAT, MADAM TREASURER
AND THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ARE
INVOLVED IN THE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY. YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM TWO EIGHT.
ALLEN I RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER NO. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO.
NO. JOBO. NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE. SATO. NO.
SKINNER. I SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. MCGUIRE. PADILLA ROTH.
AYES. 25. NOES TEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ITEM 211, SENATOR
ROTH. HE IS READY. SECRETARY,
YOU MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2304
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL ACTIONS.
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. UNDER CURRENT LAW,
WHEN A LANDLORD DECIDES TO TAKE
A TENANT INTO THE EVICTION
PROCESS, THE COURT RECORD IS
MASKED UNLESS THE LANDLORD
PREVAILS WITHIN 60 DAYS. IF THE
TENANT PREVAILS OR THE CASE IS
WITHDRAWN, THEN THE RECORD
REMAINS MASKED. ON THE CONTRARY,
IF THE LANDLORD PREVAILS, THEN
THE RECORD MAY BE RELEASED,
RESULTING IN THE TENANT ENDING
UP WITH A MARK ON THEIR CREDIT
RECORD. THIS BILL EXTENDS THE
RECORD MASKING PROTECTION TO
MOBILE HOME PARK TENANTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 211. ALLEN I'LL
ROLL TO GILL NØ ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DELHI NØ. DODD AYE. D'ORAZIO
AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LOWMAN
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO NO. COBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY.
AYE BLAKE. SPEER. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER AYE. MCGUIRE. AYES
30. NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. I WAS JUST ABOUT TO SAY.
GIVE A SENATE. WELCOME TO FORMER
SENATOR HUESO. BUT HE
DISAPPEARED. HE WAS UP IN THE
GALLERY FOR A FEW MINUTES AGO.
ALL RIGHT. HUESO STILL HERE? HE
LEFT. OKAY. GOT IT. ALL RIGHT.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 218. SENATOR WIENER.
HE HAS PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2503 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. WE NEED SOME
WD 40 OVER HERE. I THINK.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2503 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE,
WHICH EXEMPTS FROM CEQA THE
DELIVERY OF ZERO EMISSION TRAIN
PROJECTS AND HELPS REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED TO HELP
US ACHIEVE ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE,
AIR QUALITY AND EQUITY GOALS.
ELECTRIFIED AND OTHER ZERO
EMISSION TRAINS WILL HELP REDUCE
SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION,
INCLUDING FROM SOURCES SUCH AS
NITRIC OXIDE, OZONE AND OTHER
PARTICULATE MATTER THAT ACUTELY
AFFECTS FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
WHILE HELPING MAKE TRAINS FASTER
AND MORE FREQUENT. THESE
PROJECTS ARE BENEFICIAL FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND SHOULD NOT BE HELD UP BY RED
TAPE. THIS BILL BUILDS OFF OF
EXISTING CEQA EXEMPTIONS FOR
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS, WHICH I AUTHORED IN
SENATE BILL 288 AND SENATE BILL
922 PASSED BY THIS BODY. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT. WE
MUST DO MORE TO BUILD A CLIMATE
FRIENDLY TRANSPORTATION FUTURE,
AND AB 2503 HELPS ACHIEVE THAT
VISION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING. NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL. ELLEN Ã ALVARADO. GIL
ARCHULETA I. ASHBY I. ATKINS, I.
BECKER I. BLAKE. SPEER. I.
BRADFORD. I. CABALLERO I. CORTEZ
I. DALLEY DODD I. DURAZO I.
EGGMAN I. GLASER. I. GONZALEZ I.
GROVE NØ. HURTADO I. JONES NØ.
LAIRD I. LOWMAN MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I. MEN I. NEWMAN, I.
NGUYEN. NÓ NILO. PADILLA I.
PORTANTINO I. ROTH I. RUBIO I.
SEYARTO. NÓ SKINNER. I SMILED.
CUEVAS I. STERN, I. UMBERG, I.
WAHHAB I. WIENER. I. WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL DALLEY. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE. NILO. NÓ OCHOA. BOGH.
AYES 30. NOES FIVE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 220.
SENATOR NIELLO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2618 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN. AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2618 BY ASSEMBLYMAN CHEN. AB
2618 EXTENDS AN EXISTING SUNSET
DATE THAT GRANTS LOCAL AGENCIES
THE AUTHORITY TO INVEST UP TO
50%, RATHER THAN 30% OF ITS
SURPLUS FUNDS IN DEPOSITS AT A
COMMERCIAL BANK, SAVINGS BANK,
SAVINGS AND LOAN ASSOCIATION OR
CREDIT UNION. FROM JANUARY 1ST
OF 2026 TO JANUARY 1ST OF 2031.
THE MEASURE MAINTAINS
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
AND BANKS AS THEY WORK TOGETHER
IN MANAGING LOCAL AGENCY FUNDS
AND IN SERVICING THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
HEARING AND SEEING. NONE. AYES
39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FINAL
ITEM 227. SENATOR LAIRD. HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2723 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATION DATA AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL PROVIDES
UPDATES TO THE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM. I REPRESENT THE
SENATE. THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
REPRESENTS THE ASSEMBLY ON THE
BOARD. THIS IS RELATIVELY NEW,
AND WITH ANY NEW ENTITY, THERE
ARE ASPECTS OF ITS GOVERNING
STATUTE THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM
REFINEMENTS OF THIS BILL.
CLARIFIES THE ROLE IN RELATION
TO DATA THAT IS MAINTAINED AND
IMPORTANTLY, DIRECTS
CALIFORNIANS WHO WANT TO
EXERCISE THEIR PRIVACY RIGHTS TO
DATA PROVIDERS WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HONOR THESE RIGHTS.
THERE'S SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FOR ITEM
227? SEEING NONE, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TWO. TWO.
SEVEN. ALL RIGHT. YES OKAY.
MEMBERS, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING.
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING.
NONE. AYES 39. ON THE URGENCY.
ALL RIGHT. WE DO HAVE AN
OBJECTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. HI. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE HURTADO.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE. OKOBO AYE. PURDUE AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER I
SMILED. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB NØ. WIENER
AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HURTADO AYE.
LIMON MCGUIRE. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ONE MORE TIME. LEMON I. AYES 39.
NOES ONE ON THE URGENCY. AYES
39. NOES ONE ON THE MEASURE.
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
228. SENATOR DURAZZO IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2735 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCO RUBIO. AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER CORPORATIONS.
SENATOR DURAZZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 2735 RISES OUT OF
CLEAR NEED TO PROTECT BOTH
CONSUMERS AND OUR WATER
PROVIDERS FROM UNCERTAINTY POSED
BY THE CURRENT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE MARKET.
THIS BILL LOOKS TO PROVIDE
STABILITY FOR THE EXISTING
MARKET BY ESTABLISHING AN
ALTERNATIVE INSURANCE OPTION FOR
OUR STATE'S WATER PROVIDERS. THE
CALIFORNIA FAIR PLAN HAS
PROVIDED A BACKSTOP FOR ENTITIES
SEEKING COVERAGE WHEN THEY
OTHERWISE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO.
HOWEVER, IT HAS BECOME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT THIS
EXISTING SYSTEM IS IN JEOPARDY.
THIS IS BEING FELT BY THE WATER
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE. AB
2735 PROVIDES A UNIQUE,
EXPLICITLY PERMISSIVE SOLUTION
TO THE COMPLEX PROBLEM FOR OUR
WATER PROVIDERS. THIS BILL WOULD
HELP STABILIZE WATER RATES WHILE
STABILIZING THE UTILIZATION OF
THE FAIR PLAN. IT'S A MODEL FOR
OTHER UTILITIES, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 228. ALAN A GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. DODD.
AYE. BARRASSO EGGMAN. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
OR TOTO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE A.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB NØ. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA. AYE DALLEY.
AYE MOORLACH. RIVAS. AYE. TO. NO
DURAZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE. AYES
38. NOES TWO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
TWO. THREE TWO. SENATOR DURAZO.
AGAIN SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2847 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OTIS. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICAL AND GAS CORPORATIONS.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, IT'S
NO SECRET. ENERGY RATES ARE
SKYROCKETING, IMPACTING REAL
PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA, AND
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY
THEIR MONTHLY BILLS. OUR
RESIDENTS OF OUR STATE DESERVE
TO KNOW TWO THINGS WHAT TO
EXPECT WHEN THEY OPEN THEIR
MONTHLY ENERGY BILL, AND THAT
ALL OF THE COSTS INCLUDED IN
THEIR BILL ARE FAIR AND
REASONABLE. THIS BILL WILL SHINE
A LIGHT ON THE LONG TERM IMPACT
OF UTILITIES CHOICES. IT WILL
REQUIRE UTILITIES PROVIDE
ESTIMATES OF THE LONG TERM COSTS
OF THEIR CAPITAL EXPENSES UP
FRONT WHEN MAKING THEIR CASE TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
RECENT AMENDMENTS ADD IMPORTANT
GUARDRAILS, GUARDRAILS TO THE
BILL ONLY REQUIRING THESE
ESTIMATES WHEN THE COMMISSION
DETERMINES THEY ARE NECESSARY.
THIS WILL ENSURE THE COMMISSION
RATEPAYERS, ADVOCATES AND HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER UTILITIES
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO PASS THESE
COSTS ALONG TO THEIR CUSTOMERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON PHÐ. ITEM 323. ALLEN Ã
ALVARADO GÒM NØ. ARCHULETA ASHBY.
ATKINS. ASHBY I. ATKINS I.
BECKER I. BLAKE. SPEER I.
BRADFORD I. CABALLERO I. CORTEZ
I. DALLEY NÓ. DODD I. DURAZO I.
EGGMAN I. GLAZER GONZALEZ I.
GROVE NØ. HURTADO I. JONES NØ.
LAIRD I. LIMÓN I. MCGUIRE I.
MENGIBAR I. MIN NEWMAN. NGUYEN
NILO I CHIRLA. BOGUE NØ. PADILLA
I. PORTANTINO I. ROTH RUBIO I.
SEYARTO. NÓ. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS I. STERN. I UMBERG, I.
WAHAB I. WIENER I. WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. I GLAZER, I. MIN. I.
NEWMAN I. NGUYEN. NØ. NILO NO.
ROTH I. AYES 32. NOES EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 243. SENATOR WIENER,
HE IS READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ TRAUMATIZED FILE ASSEMBLY
BILL 3206 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKINNON. AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. SENATOR
WIENER, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
32 SIX ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCKENNA. THIS BILL ALLOWS
FOR A SPECIFIC ENTERTAINMENT
VENUE IN INGLEWOOD TO OFFER
AFTER HOURS ALCOHOL SALES UNDER
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES,
SUNSETTING IN 2030. AS
CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE SEEKING TO
NAVIGATE A GROWING DEMAND FOR
RETAIL ALCOHOL SALES AFTER 2
A.M, AB 3206 TAKES A NEW
APPROACH TO BALANCE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. THE BILL
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF SAFEGUARDS,
INCLUDING LIMITING THE SIZE OF
THE VENUE, LIMITING THE NUMBER
OF CUSTOMERS ALLOWED IN THE
VENUE, LIMITING THE DAYS THAT
THE VENUE CAN OFFER AFTER HOUR
ALCOHOL SALES, AND REQUIRING
LOCAL APPROVAL TO MITIGATE
POTENTIAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS. THIS BILL IS A
NARROW BILL THAT ALLOWS FOR A
SPECIFIC VENUE, NOT AN ENTIRE
CITY, TO OFFER THESE SALES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR CIERTO. AYE.
MEMBERS I OPPOSE THIS. THIS BILL,
THIS IS ACTUALLY A VERY
EXCLUSIVE CLUB INSIDE A VENUE
THAT'S BEING BUILT RIGHT NOW
THAT WILL ONLY ALLOW EXCLUSIVE
MEMBERS TO DRINK UNTIL 4:00 IN
THE MORNING, AND THEN WE TURN
THEM LOOSE ON THE STREETS OF
INGLEWOOD, WHICH IS A CITY THAT
I USED TO SERVE. THAT IS THE
LAST THING THAT THAT CITY NEEDS.
IF THEY THINK THAT OPENING
VENUES AND HAVING DRINKING TILL
4:00 IN THE MORNING IS GOOD FOR
JUST EXCLUSIVE GROUPS, THEN IT
SHOULD BE FOR EVERYONE. AND MY
CONTENTION IS IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
ANYONE. SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE A
NO VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? SENATOR
ASHBY? YES. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. I JUST WANTED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
ROOM AND SAY THAT IT IS A VERY
NARROW, NARROWLY TAILORED
EXCEPTION AND URGE. AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DURAZZO. YES,
I, I AGREE WITH MANY OF THE
ISSUES RAISED BY THIS BILL, AND
I'M GOING TO TRY IN THE FUTURE
TO PAY MORE ATTENTION THAT THIS
DOESN'T BECOME ONE EXAMPLE AFTER
ANOTHER, AFTER ANOTHER, BUT
BECAUSE IT'S EXTREMELY NARROW, I
WILL SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING
SEEING NONE. SENATOR WIENER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKINNON, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM TWO FOR THREE. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL NO. ARCHULETA. I
ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER. BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALY NÓ DODD I DURAZZO
I EGGMAN. GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NO. HURTADO I JONES.
LAIRD LIMÓN I MAGUIRE I MENGIBAR.
NO. MEN NEWMAN. NGUYEN. NO NILO.
NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO.
SEYARTO NO. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS I STERN. UMBERG WAHAB. NO
WIENER I WILK. NO SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BLAKE. SPEER BECKMAN. JONES
LAIRD. MIN. NO NEWMAN. RUBIO
STERN. I UMBERG I. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BLAKE. SPEAR
NO. EGGMAN JONES. LAIRD NEWMAN.
RUBIO. AYES 23. NOES 12. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM 246.
SENATOR STERN IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2513 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN. AN ACT RELATING
TO GAS STOVES. SENATOR STERN,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YES. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
THIS WOULD BE A CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE CONSUMER LABELS ON
CERTAIN HOME KITCHEN APPLIANCES
TO ENSURE THAT THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENTIFIC DATA IS
MADE AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS.
DISCLOSING RISKS OF INDOOR AIR
POLLUTION, EXPOSURE TO NITROGEN
DIOXIDE, CARBON MONOXIDE,
BENZENE AND OTHER CARCINOGENIC
BYPRODUCTS THAT CAN CAUSE
HARMFUL HEALTH EFFECTS,
INCLUDING CHILDHOOD ASTHMA. BY
MAKING THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS, THIS
BILL WILL HELP MAKE PURCHASERS
MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTIVE OF
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION,
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS,
BREAST CARE PREVENTION PARTNERS,
SIERRA CLUB RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER.
I BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO CORTEZ I DAWLEY. NO.
DODD. NO DURAZO I EGGMAN, I
GLASER. GONZALEZ I GROVE. NO.
HURTADO JONES. NO. LAIRD I
LOWMAN I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
OKOBOJI. NO PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
ROTH RUBIO. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN. I
UMBERG. WAHAB I WIENER. I WILK.
NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. NO EGGMAN. IDA. NO.
ASHBY ATKINS. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. GLAZER RIDOTTO
MCGUIRE. MEN NEWMAN. PORTANTINO
ROTH. RUBIO UMBERG. SENATOR
STERN MOVES THE CALL. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL. ITEM 249. SENATOR JONES.
JONES. JONES. SENATOR JONES, ARE
YOU PREPARED? SURE. SECRETARY,
YOU MAY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1890
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE
PATTERSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC WORKS. SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I'M PRESENTING FILE
ITEM 249 BY OUR ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE IN THE ASSEMBLY, JOE
PATTERSON. 1890 WILL REQUIRE
AWARDING AGENCIES OF PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS TO UPDATE THEIR
PROJECT REGISTRATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND SITUATIONS. WHEN A
CONTRACTOR OR SUBCONTRACTOR
PERFORMING WORK ON AN EXISTING
PROJECT IS CHANGED, OR THE TOTAL
COST OF THE PUBLIC WORKS
CONTRACT CHANGES ON BEHALF, I'M
PRESENTING THIS ON BEHALF OF JOE
PATERSON. IN 1890. IS SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA, NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS, AND RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS VOTE. I ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL ON
THIS ITEM. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 249.
ALLEN. ALVARADO. GIL A ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER. I
BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DAWLEY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR I MEN, I NEWMAN. I
NGUYEN I MILO, I COBO I PODIUM,
I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO, I
SEYARTO, I SKINNER, I SMILED, I
STERN, I UMBERG, I WAHAB I
WEINER I WILK I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN I GLAZER I
GROVE I. AYES 40 NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 254.
SENATOR GLAZIER HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2443 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO. AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
GLAZIER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
GOOD WORK TODAY, I APPRECIATE
IT. ON BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, JUAN CARRILLO, THIS IS A
DISTRICT SPECIFIC BILL THAT
WOULD ALLOW THREE CITIES
VICTORVILLE, LANCASTER AND
PALMDALE TO IMPOSE A TRANSACTION
AND USE TAX TO SUPPORT
COUNTYWIDE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS AND GENERAL SERVICES AT
A RATE OF NO MORE THAN 1%. THE
BOARD ARE RESPECTIVE CITY
COUNCIL MUST ADOPT AN ORDINANCE
PROPOSING THE TAX, AND THE
VOTERS MUST APPROVE IT. THE BILL
WOULD RAISE CRITICAL RESOURCES
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR A
DISTRICT THAT HAS BEEN
HISTORICALLY LEFT BEHIND, AND
WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, SENATOR WILK? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I TYPICALLY DO
NOT VOTE FOR ANYTHING THAT WOULD
RESEMBLE A TAX INCREASE, BUT
THESE THREE CITIES HAPPENED TO
BE IN MY SENATORIAL DISTRICT,
AND THEY HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDERFUNDED. WHETHER IT'S BEEN
DOWNTOWN LA OR DOWNTOWN SAN
BERNARDINO. AND THEY ARE WILLING
TO TAKE ON THE BURDEN THEMSELVES
TO BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
OUR FORMER PARTY LOVES SO MUCH,
AND TO HAVE A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE. SO I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH TAXES IF IT HAS A DIRECT
CORRELATION TO SOMETHING THAT
BENEFITS THE PEOPLE. SO WITH
THAT, I'M GOING TO BE VOTING AYE
ON THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. SENATOR GLAZIER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SENATOR WILK
HAS SAID IT. WELL, IT'S A LOCAL
CONTROL CHOICE. MONEY AND
RESOURCES THAT ARE RAISED GO
DIRECTLY TO THOSE JURISDICTIONS.
WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
FINAL ITEM. 254. ALLEN Ã
ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA, ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ DODD. AYE. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN.
AYE. MAGUIRE MENJIVAR. AYE. MIN
NO. NEWMAN AYE. WAYNE NO. NO.
NILO NO. CHOBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO SATO. NO SKINNER A
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. AYE. WILK. AYE AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL. NO ARCHULETA. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE 30
NO'S NINE. THE MEASURE PASSES ON
THE URGENCY. AYES 30. NOS. NINE
ON THE URGENCY. AYES 30. NOS.
NINE ON THE MEASURE. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO FALL.
ITEM 255. SENATOR STERN, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY, YOU CAN
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1983 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. AN
ACT RELATING TO TAXATION AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION.
THEREFORE, SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
THIS BILL REINSTATES A TAX
CHECKOFF PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE, WHICH ALLOWS
CALIFORNIANS TO DONATE A PORTION
OF THEIR TAX REFUND TO FUND
GRANTS FOR LOW COST FREE SPAY
AND NEUTER PROGRAMS. WITH RISING
VETERINARY COSTS AND LIMITED
ACCESS TO CARE FOR PET
OVERPOPULATION SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE, THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NONE
MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL TO ITEM 255? SEEING
NONE AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM 267. SENATOR LEMON, SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2541 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAYNES. AN ACT
RELATING TO PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING. THANK YOU, SENATOR
LAMONT. THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. AB 2541, AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOCTOR JASMEET
BAINS, WILL DIRECT POST TO
CREATE GUIDELINES TO ADDRESS
WANDERING. WANDERING OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE, AUTISM OR
DEMENTIA. AB 2541 HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS PASSED
THROUGH BOTH HOUSES WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. MEMBERS.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL TO THIS MEASURE?
HEARING. SEEING NONE. AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 280.
SENATOR DODD, HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2832 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD. AN ACT RELATING TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2832 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES FUNDS EXPENDED FROM
THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
EXPORT PROMOTION ACCOUNT TO BE
USED FOR ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES
TO PROMOTE PROMOTE THE SALE OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
IN FOREIGN MARKETS, AND EXPANDS
CURRENT AUTHORITY FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TO
PROMOTE INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENT. RESPECTFULLY ASKED
FOR YOUR I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL? SEEING NONE. AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THIS MEASURE PASSES.
NOW TO ITEM 291. SENATOR WHO'S
ALWAYS READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2628 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART. AN ACT
RELATING TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THIS BILL MODIFIES THE
SCHEDULE OF JUDICIAL BRANCH
AUDITS AND MANDATES THAT THE
STATE AUDITOR PUBLISH ANNUAL
REPORTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON A
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE.
THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING. NONE.
THIS TOOL IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTIONS TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 30. Þ.
THE AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM 292. SENATOR DALY. HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1902 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALANIS. AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALING ARTS. SENATOR DALY.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I AM
PRESENTING AB 1902 ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR ALANIS. AB 1902 WOULD
REQUIRE PHARMACY DISPENSERS TO
PROVIDE ACCESSIBLE PRESCRIPTION
LABELS TO PATIENTS WHO ARE BLIND
OR HAVE LOW VISION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE. AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
TO TAKE THE NOISE OFF THE FLOOR.
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO HEAR RIGHT
NOW, SO PLEASE. WE'RE MOVING ON
TO ITEM 297. SENATOR. MEN. HE'S
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 325 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALENCIA. AN ACT RELATING
TO COUNTY EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT.
SENATOR. MEN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS SUPPORT.
SUPPORT. IT SAFEGUARDS COUNTY
PENSIONS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? THERE IS
NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? SEEING NONE. AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THIS MEASURE PASSES.
NOW TO FILE ITEM 298. SENATOR
PADILLA. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2553 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. AND AN
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2553 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SET LOWER TRAFFIC
IMPACT MITIGATION FEES FOR
TRANSIT ORIENTED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS NEAR MAJOR TRANSIT
STOPS OR TRANSIT PRIORITY AREA,
INSTEAD OF JUST A TRANSIT
STATION. IT ALSO UPDATES THE
DEFINITION OF MAJOR TRANSIT STOP
TO REFLECT POST-COVID SERVICE
LEVELS. THE MITIGATION FEE ACT
REQUIRES IMPACT FEES TO BE SET
AT A LOWER RATE FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT
GENERATE REDUCED VEHICULAR
TRIPS. CURRENTLY, THE LAW
REQUIRES THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
TO BE WITHIN ONE HALF MILE OF A
TRANSIT STATION, WHICH IS A
NARROW DEFINITION THAT EXCLUDES
MANY PROJECTS WELL SERVED BY
TRANSIT. THIS BILL REQUIRES
LOCAL AGENCIES TO CONSIDER
REDUCING IMPACT FEES FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IMPACTS UNDER THE
NEW DEFINITIONS, WHICH WILL IN
EFFECT INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
DEVELOPMENTS THAT QUALIFY FOR
REDUCTION COMPARED TO THE
CURRENT DEFINITION. THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 298. ELLEN I RATHER
GO. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN MELO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLEY GROVE. MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA AYE.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. DOLLY
GROVE. MCGUIRE. AYES 33. NO'S
FOUR. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM TWO. NINE
NINE. SENATOR JOE BOGUE. SHE'S
READY. SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2053 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHES. AN ACT RELATING
TO PUPIL INSTRUCTION. MR.
SENATOR JOE BOGUE, MR. PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 2053 WHICH REQUIRES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
ON PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
AVAILABLE REGARDING ADOLESCENT
RELATIONSHIP ABUSE AND INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE. MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WOULD
RECEIVE THIS IMPORTANT
INFORMATION DURING THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION COURSES. THE BILL
PASSED BOTH HOUSES WITH
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
SEEING NONE. AYES 39. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING
ON TO ITEM 3.15, SENATOR LAIRD.
SECRETARY MAY READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2176 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
JUVENILES. SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AB 2176
REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION TO
MAINTAIN AN ANNUAL REPORT ON
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM RATES IN
JUVENILE COURT SCHOOLS. IT ALSO
ALLOWS THE OFFICE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM IN A COURT
SCHOOL. OTHER SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER? SEEING NONE, THIS Tð IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES
39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 317,
SENATOR RUBIO. SHE'S GETTING
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2371 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICAL
ELECTRIFIED SECURITY FENCES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2371 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO.
THIS BILL BUILDS ON THE TRACK
RECORD OF EXISTING LAW TO
ADDRESS THE ESCALATING INCIDENTS
OF PROPERTY THEFT AND DAMAGE
AGAINST GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
BUSINESSES THAT STORE HEAVY
INVENTORY. THESE FENCES SERVE AS
A DETERRENT AND ARE EFFECTIVE
WAY TO SET UP AN ALARM,
PARTICULARLY FOR BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE EQUIPMENT OR INVENTORIES
THAT MUST BE STORED OUTDOORS.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO GIVE
OUR LOCAL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING THE ABILITY TO
SAFEGUARD THEIR INVENTORY AND
FACILITIES, AS WELL AS THEIR
LIVELIHOOD, BY ALLOWING THIS
ACCESS TO A SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
TOOL TO PROTECT THEIR PROPERTY.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? SEEING NONE. AYES 39. NO
ZERO. ON THE URGENCY. AYES 39.
NØ ZERO ON THE MEASURE. MEASURE
PASSES. NOW TO FILE ITEM 321.
CORTEZ CENTER. HE'S READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3234 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA. AN ACT RELATING
TO PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR
CORTEZ, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
WELL, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SENATORS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
3234 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIZ ORTEGA. THIS IS A
BILL THAT SIMPLY REQUIRES
COMPANIES WHO VOLUNTARILY
UNDERGO A SOCIAL COMPLIANCE
AUDIT TO POST THOSE FINDINGS OF
THAT AUDIT RELATING TO CHILD
LABOR ON THEIR WEBSITE. THE
SOCIAL COMPLIANCE AUDIT IS A
NON-GOVERNMENTAL AUDIT BY A
PRIVATE FIRM THAT REVIEWS THE
FACILITY TO ENSURE THAT AN
EMPLOYER IS COMPLIANT WITH ALL
APPLICABLE LABOR LAWS. THE BILL
PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY. IT ALLOWS
CONSUMERS TO SUPPORT COMPANIES
THAT FOLLOW LABOR LAWS AND
COMPANIES SHAREHOLDERS TO KNOW
HOW THEY ARE PERFORMING AND WHEN
THEY NEED TO IMPROVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON. FINAL ITEM
THREE. TWO ONE. ALLEN Ã
ALVARADO. GÒM ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY, I. ATKINS, I. BECKER I.
BLAKESBERG I. BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I. CORTEZ I. DALLEY
DODD I. DURAZZO I. EGGMAN GLAZER
I. GONZALEZ I. GROVE I. HURTADO
I. JONES LAIRD I. LEHMAN I.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. I MEAN, I.
NEWMAN, I. NGUYEN NILO. I EBCLC.
PADILLA, I. PORTANTINO I. ROTH,
I. RUBIO I. SEYARTO SKINNER, I.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I. STERN, I.
UMBERG I. WAHAB I. WIENER I.
WILK I. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GILL. DALLEY
EGGMAN. I JONES. I MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN I. COBO SEYARTO. AGE 35.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM THREE TWO, TWO. SENATOR
LEMON. SHE IS READY. SECRETARY,
YOU MAY READ. WHAT? ASSEMBLY
BILL 310. I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY,
I'M SORRY I MISSED SENATOR JOE.
IT'S THREE TWO. TWO. OCHOA VOTE.
MY BAD. SHE'S READY. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 310
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ARAMBULA AN
ACT RELATING TO STATE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS. SENATOR
ROBERT. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 310 WHICH WILL
REQUIRE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITH INFORMATION ON
THE AMOUNT BUDGETED AND SPENT
FOR CIVIL SERVICE. PSYCHIATRIST
SERVING AT CALIFORNIA STATE
HOSPITALS. THIS DATA WILL BE
USED TO INFORM FUTURE POLICIES
THAT WILL ENSURE SAFE STAFFING
LEVELS AND IMPROVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES. WE MUST DO MORE TO
ENSURE THE WORK PERFORMED AT OUR
STATE HOSPITALS RESULT IN THE
MAXIMUM BENEFIT TO PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PATIENT SUCCESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR CORTEZ, ARE YOU UP
ON THIS ITEM? I SEE YOUR MIC.
OKAY. I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
SHE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SECRETARY,
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
TWO. 22322. ALAN Ã. I'LL
RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE. OR
DATO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEUMANN.
AYE. NGUYEN MELO. PATROL BOAT.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. TALLEY. AYE MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN. AYE. MILO. AYE AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS. WE'RE DOWN TO OUR FINAL
TEN ITEMS. WE'RE DOING GOOD.
MAKING GOOD PACE. BUT WE NEED TO
KEEP THE NOISE DOWN SO WE CAN
KEEP ON MOVING AND GET THROUGH
THIS. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 323. SENATOR LIMÓN. SHE'S
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2633 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ. AN ACT RELATING
TO POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR LIMÓN, THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ TO
PRESENT AB 2633, WHICH WOULD
ALLOW CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY TO AWARD JOINT
UNDERGRADUATE, GRADUATE AND
DOCTORAL DEGREES IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH INTERNATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
AB 2633 HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? SEEING NONE AYES 39. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 331.
SENATOR LAIRD, HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1137 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES-SAWYER AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT.
SENATOR. LAIRD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 1137 WILL ENSURE
FAIRNESS IN STATE EMPLOYMENT BY
PROVIDING EQUITABLE BENEFITS TO
STATE SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS.
CURRENTLY EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES
SUCH AS STATE SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS, DO NOT HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS AND ARE ONLY
ABLE TO ACCESS BETTER BENEFITS
THROUGH LEGISLATION. THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE THE STATE
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS WITH
NOTIFICATION WHEN THEY ARE
DENIED A MERIT BASED SALARY
ADJUSTMENT AND WITH OVERTIME PAY
FOR TIME WORKED ON PREMIUM
HOLIDAYS. IT WILL PROVIDE SOME
EQUITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 331. ALAN AYE, I'LL
RODA-GIL NØ ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBURG AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY NO. DODD. AYE. RAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO. DATO.
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN MILO. NO. JOBO NO.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO.
NÓ. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN. ICE 31 NOES
SEVEN. THE MEASURE PASSES NOW.
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM
401. SENATE-TV. PORTANTINO ARE
YOU FOR? I'M SORRY. 402 SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2889 ONE MINUTE.
MR. SENATOR, LET THE SECRETARY
READ, PLEASE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2889
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZEBRA. AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS. SENATOR
PORTANTINO THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ZUBIATE TO PRESENT AB 2889 WHICH
HELPS RESOLVE LABOR DISPUTES.
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
AND WITHIN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND CITY OF LOS ANGELES
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RELATIONS BOARD
CURRENTLY HAS OVERSIGHT
JURISDICTION OVER DISPUTES
BETWEEN ALMOST ALL PUBLIC AGENCY
EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS.
HOWEVER, CURRENT LAW PROVIDES
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WITH A LOCAL ALTERNATIVE
TO PERB OVERSIGHT. THESE LOCAL
ALTERNATIVES, WHICH ARE LOCAL
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ENTITIES,
HAVE THE POWER TO INVESTIGATE
UNFAIR PRACTICE CHARGES AND THE
LOCAL BODIES DO NOT AFFORD OUR
WORKERS WITH THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED BY PERB.
THIS BILL IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
ALIGNING LABOR PRACTICES ACROSS
THE STATE, IT'S ALSO ABOUT
FAIRNESS FOR ALL PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA. AB 2889
PROVIDES PERB WITH EXCLUSIVE
INITIAL JURISDICTION OVER
REQUESTS FOR INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
BY BOTH THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES, JUST AS ALREADY HAS
FOR OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
THE REST OF THE STATE. IT ALSO
CLARIFIES THAT LOCAL EMPLOYEES
RELATION ENTITIES IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY DO NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO AWARD DAMAGES
RESULTING FROM A STRIKE. THIS
ENSURES THAT LOCAL PUBLIC SECTOR
UNIONS AND THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS FROM UNION BUSTING
TACTICS THAT ALL OTHER UNIONS
UNDER PERB JURISDICTIONS HAVE,
AND I RESPECTFULLY. THE BILL IS
SPONSORED BY SEIU CALIFORNIA AND
ACM CALIFORNIA AND THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FOUL LINE 402. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GILBERT NÓ ARCHULETA I
ASHBY. I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPUR. I BRADFORD I. CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALY NÓ DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NÓ HURTADO I JONES. NØ.
LAIRD I LIMON. I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN. I
NGUYEN. NØ. NILO NO COBO. NO
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROD I
RUBIO I SATO NO SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK. NÓ PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER
MCGUIRE. AYES 29. NO'S NINE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE. FILE ITEM 412. SENATOR
DURAZO SHE HAS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3042 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES-SAWYER AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR DURAZO THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 3142 EXPANDS THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CHANGE
EDUCATION CENTER AT WEST LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE BY ADDING A
MOBILE UNIT IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
THE REACH OF THE CURRENT CENTER.
THIS BILL FOLLOWS EFFORTS FROM
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO MEET
FUTURE WORKFORCE NEEDS IN
CLIMATE ACTION, INCLUDING THE
CREATION OF THE CLIMATE CHANGE
EDUCATION CENTER AT WEST LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE. THIS BILL WILL
FURTHER THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN BY
HELPING THE CLIMATE CHANGE
EDUCATION CENTER REACH STUDENTS
WHERE THEY'RE AT WITH HANDS ON
LEARNING AND INTERNSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES, AND CODIFYING THE
CENTER IN STATE LAW. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. HEARING
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GÒM.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE OR DOTTO? AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
NAVARRE. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NHIÀU. AYE.
B¢O. AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO I. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE SATO. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALY GROVE. JONES
MCGUIRE. SEYARTO WAHAB. AYE.
AYES 35. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 4.75,
SENATOR DODD. HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2622 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO. AN ACT
RELATING TO CONTRACTORS. SENATOR
DODD. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS. TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2622 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO. THIS
BIPARTISAN BILL RAISES THE
MINIMUM WORK EXEMPTION FOR
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS FROM $500
TO 1000, PROVIDED THAT THESE
PROFESSIONALS DO NOT UNDERTAKE
PROJECTS REQUIRING A BUILDING
PERMIT AND DO NOT HIRE ANY
EMPLOYEES. CURRENTLY, THE LABOR
AND MATERIAL COSTS OF SIMPLE
PROJECTS EASILY SURPASS $500,
MEANING THAT UNLICENSED
PROFESSIONALS ARE TAKING ON
THESE SMALL JOBS ILLEGALLY. BY
INCREASING THE THRESHOLD, AB
2622 ENSURES HANDYMEN CAN
QUICKLY AND LEGALLY BUILD A
PORTFOLIO AND EVENTUALLY QUALIFY
FOR AN EXAM WAIVER. THIS BILL IS
ALSO AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
ENSURING THAT HANDYMEN CAN MAKE
A LIVING, WHILE ALSO PROTECTING
CONSUMERS AND HOPEFULLY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
POTENTIAL LICENSEES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. AYES 39. NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW ON TO
FILE ITEM 561. SENATOR DURAZO
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2586 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE THIS BILL BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ. EVERY
DAY, UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TAKE
A RISK DESPITE UNJUST BARRIERS
THAT THEY COME ACROSS. THEY
CONTINUE TO BE PERSISTENT,
RESILIENT AND BRILLIANT
STUDENTS. HOWEVER, THESE
STUDENTS ARE UNABLE TO BE PAID
FOR THEIR WORK OR OBTAIN ON
CAMPUS JOBS, WHICH SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTS THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
PAYMENTS TOWARD THEIR TUITION,
SUPPLIES, HOUSING, AND OTHER
BASIC NEEDS. CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO 83,000 UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
HOWEVER, THE NUMBER OF DACA
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS ON CAMPUSES
HAS BEEN CONSISTENTLY DECREASING
AS COURT RESTRICTIONS AND
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA NARROW.
ACCESS FOR THIS YOUNG
GENERATION. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS TO CAMPUS
CAMPUS EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THESE STUDENTS WHILE THEY
EARN THEIR DEGREES, REGARDLESS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. AT
THE èC, CAL STATES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, DOZENS OF
THE NATION'S LEADING LEGAL
SCHOLARS HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT
THE FEDERAL PROHIBITION ON
HIRING UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE DOES
NOT INCLUDE STATE ENTITIES LIKE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY, AND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
2856 AB 28 586 ALLOWS STUDENTS
TO BE IN THE APPLICANT POOL AND
LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
OPPORTUNITIES. THESE ARE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN VETTED
BY OUR ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS.
THESE ARE STUDENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROMISED THAT IF THEY WORK
HARD, THEY WILL HAVE A FUTURE.
WE HAVE INVESTED IN THEM AND NOW
WE NEED TO GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY, TO WORK AB 2586
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY,
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL IS WHAT WE
NEED. I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE? HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE GILL.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY NO. DODD.
AYE. RAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
MILO. OKOBO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. GILL. NO
GROVE. NO LIMON. AYE MCGUIRE.
MIN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
COBO AYE. STURDY NOES EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW. MEMBERS.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIX TWO.
THREE. SENATOR DODD, HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2428 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. AN ACT RELATING
TO MEDI-CAL. SENATOR DODD, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I
RES RES I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2428 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LISA CALDERON.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2428 ESTABLISHES
THE MEDI-CAL FEE FOR SERVICE
RATE AS A FLOOR IN THE MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE PLAN. CONTRACTS
WITH COMMUNITY BASED ADULT DAY
SERVICE PROVIDERS. THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT A VULNERABLE
AND GROWING POPULATION OF
ELDERLY CALIFORNIANS CAN STILL
ACCESS THESE SERVICES FOR YEARS
TO COME. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. I
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING. NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? HEARING AND SEEING. NONE.
AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS. WE'RE MOVING
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR LEMON, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION. FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON FILE ITEM
243. AB 3206. ALL RIGHT. THAT'S
WHAT I DO. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THAT, SENATOR DODD?
NO. SENATOR ARCHULETA'S
OBJECTION.
SEEING NO OBJECTION.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED. AYES
30 900.
SECRETARY, NOW, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON. ITEM 243. ALLEN Ã
ALVARADO. ARCHULETA I. ASHBY I.
ATKINS, I. BECKER I. BLAKESBERG
BRADFORD I. CABALLERO I. CORTEZ
I. DALLEY DODD I. DURAZZO. I.
EGGMAN I. GLAZER GONZALEZ I.
GROVE NØ. HURTADO I. JONES LAIRD.
LIMÓN MCGUIRE I. MENGIBAR MEN.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. NØ NILO. NÓ JOBO.
NØ. PADILLA I. PORTANTINO I.
ROTH I. RUBIO SEYARTO. NØ.
SKINNER I SMILED. GRAVES I.
STERN UMBERG, I. WAHAB. NØ.
WIENER I. WILK NO. EGGMAN. I. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL NO! BLAKE. SPEAR
NO. DALLEY NO. GLAZER JONES.
LAIRD LIMÓN. MENGIBAR. NO MEN.
NO. NEWMAN NO. RUBIO STERN I.
AYES 21. NOES 14. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. MEMBERS. NOW IS
THE TIME. SENATOR DODD. YES MR.
CHAIR, I REQUEST FROM THE AUTHOR
THAT AB 2996, FILE ITEM NUMBER
493 BE REMOVED FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE. AB 365, AB
224 AND AB 98 FROM ASSEMBLY
MAJORITY LEADER AGUIAR-CURRY.
THE DESK WILL NOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR HURTADO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE FILED ITEM
143 AB 2376 FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT FILE. THE DESK WILL NOTE
ANY ADDITIONAL ITEMS.
WHAT DO YOU NEED? A LITTLE
LOUDER?
NOW. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
LIFT A CALL. FIRST ITEM UP IS
FILE ITEM 246. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ASHBY ATKINS.
CABALLERO GLAZER. HURTADO
MCGUIRE. AYE. MIN NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO UMBERG.
MARTINEZ. BRADFORD. I DON'T KNOW.
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL. NOW.
MEMBERS. WE'RE MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. MEMBERS. WE
NEED TO KEEP THE NOISE DOWN,
PLEASE. WE'RE MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. WE HAVE
THREE ITEMS. FIRST MOVING. FIRST
ITEM IS FILE ITEM 56. SENATOR
ALLEN IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 863 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS. SENATOR ALLEN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
BILL IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. IT
GIVES THE LEGISLATURE MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE WHEN
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
APPEAR BEFORE VOTERS. THERE WERE
SOME TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING
AND SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON. FINAL
ITEM 56. ALLEN A BILL ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ. I DALLEY NÓ
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN. I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE. NØ.
HURTADO I JONES. NØ. LAIRD I
LEMON I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR MEN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN NØ NILO NØ OJOBO
NØ. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH
I RUBIO. SEYARTO NØ. SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN.
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK.
NØ PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. I'LL GÒM NØ MENGIBAR I
RUBIO I STERN I. AYES 31 NOES
NINE. THE MEASURE PASSES. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 58. WE HAVE SENATOR
CABALLERO. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1140 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. SB 1140 IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. THIS IS AN
EFFICIENCY BILL. THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY ADDRESSED
CHAPTER IN CONFLICT BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING. NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M FALLING. I'M 58. ALLEN I
ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA I ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKESBURG I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY NÓ DODD I RAZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE NÓ
HURTADO I JONES NØ. LAIRD I
LOWMAN I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I
MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NILO NÓ.
COBO PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH
I RUBIO I SEYARTO. NÓ SKINNER I
SMILED. CUEVAS I STERNE I UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GILL NGUYEN. NO PATROL
BOAT. NO AYES 32. NOES SEVEN.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 59.
SENATOR DODD SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1379 BY
SENATOR DODD, AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC RETIREMENT AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
DODD, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS SB 1379, A DISTRICT BILL
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY MAY CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 59. ALLEN I.
ALVARADO. GILL I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DAWLEY. DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE
I HURTADO I JONES. LAIRD I LIMON
I MCGUIRE. I MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN NØ. NILO I TROVO
I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. NO. SKINNER I
SMILED. CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG
I WOBBE I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS DAWLEY.
EGGMAN I JONES. NO. AYES 36.
NOES THREE. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN AYES 36. NOES
THREE. ON THE URGENCY.
MEMBERS. WE'RE ABOUT TO LIFT A
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT A CALL
ON ITEM 246. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 246. ASHBY
ATKINS. CABALLERO GLAZER.
HURTADO MEN. NEWMAN PORTANTINO
ROTH. RUBIO UMBERG. FAIL I 17.
NOES 12. THE MEASURE FAILS.
SENATOR STERN MOVES FOR
RECONSIDERATION. ANY OBJECTION
FOR RECONSIDERATION? SEEING NO
OBJECTION, RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED. AYES 39. NÓ ZERO. IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS, OVER THE LAST TWO DAYS,
THIS BODY HAS TAKEN UP
APPROXIMATELY 94, 95 BILLS
APPROXIMATELY IN THAT CATEGORY,
64 BILLS ALONE. TODAY I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THE UNIVERSE FOR THE REST OF THE
WEEK. THERE ARE TWO ISSUES THAT
THIS BODY IS GOING TO HAVE OVER
THE NEXT 48 HOURS THAT WE'RE ON
SESSION, IN SESSION ON WEDNESDAY
AND THURSDAY. NUMBER ONE, WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF BILLS THAT ARE
THAT EITHER DON'T HAVE
AMENDMENTS AND AMENDMENTS ARE
PENDING, OR TWO ARE STILL
WAITING ON FLOOR MANAGERS. SO
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN? THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE BILLS THAT ARE
IN FRONT OF THIS BODY THIS WEEK
ARE AWAITING AMENDMENTS BASED
OFF OF APPROPRIATIONS, OR THE
AUTHOR IS SEEKING AMENDMENTS TO
BE ABLE TO AMEND ON THE FLOOR.
SO THAT MEANS TOMORROW WE'RE
GOING TO COME IN AT 10 A.M. AND
I WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE AN EARLIER
ADJOURNMENT TIME TOMORROW, BASED
OFF OF THE NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
ARE STILL AWAITING AMENDMENTS
AND CANDIDLY, STILL AWAITING
FLOOR MANAGERS. THE ON THURSDAY,
FOLKS SHOULD EXPECT TO COME IN
AT 9 A.M. AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THAT WILL ALSO BE A SHORTER
SESSION. WE HAD ANTICIPATED THAT
WE WERE GOING TO BE IN FROM 9 TO
1. I WOULD ANTICIPATE WE'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE IN 9 TO 10,
9 TO 11, BUT WE'LL KNOW MORE
TOMORROW ABOUT THURSDAY AND
WE'LL GIVE EVERYONE AN UPDATE.
SO TO RECAP AND I'M GOING TO
TURN IT RIGHT BACK OVER TO MR.
PRESIDENT TOMORROW. FLOOR
SESSION IS AT 10 A.M. IT WILL BE
SHORTER THAN WHAT WE ORIGINALLY
ANTICIPATED. WE'LL LET YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH SHORTER ONCE WE GET
INTO IT. SECONDLY, 9 A.M. ON
THURSDAY, I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE FLOOR TEAM FOR THE
FANTASTIC WORK THAT THEY'RE
DOING EACH AND EVERY DAY. I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER FOR HIS WORK
ALWAYS AND HIS CAUCUS. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
WEDNESDAY, AUGUST 21ST AT 10
A.M. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU. THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED. WE'LL RECONVENE
TOMORROW, WEDNESDAY, AUGUST
21ST, AT 10 A.M.